Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen.
Willst du auch einen blauen Haken haben, nur acht Euro?
Was kosten Pinker?
Logbuch-Testpolitik Nummer 4hundertundfünfundvierzig vom, was haben wir denn heute? 8ter November 20,
zweiundzwanzig oder zweitausendzweiundzwanzig, für die Leute, die es die nicht sicher sind,
sich im Weltall und auf dem Zeitstrahl verorten da machen wir es euch einfach, sehr gerne. Und was heißt das Linus? Was heißt das.
Wir sind 11 Jahre alt. Erst 11ter Geburtstag war am 28. Oktober.
Es ist schon ist jetzt nicht so rund oder so. Okay Schnapszahl man kann sie halt beliebige Zahlen müssen heranziehen, aber ich dachte, das ist äh äh durchaus erwähnenswert.
Ja, ja ist erwähnenswert. Oder?
Gleich drüber reden.
Können wir jetzt machen.
Ja also uns gibt's jetzt seit elf Jahren.
Binär drei,
wir springen ja äh bei den bei den Jubiläen auf Hexradezimal äh vielleicht können wir in den Jahren ja dann einfach auf obwohl das bringt nix, da nur die Bienen mehr Zahlen zu feiern, dann.
Und ich würde sogar sagen, nach den elf Jahren haben wir uns langsam aneinander gewöhnt.
Ja also andere Meister sagt ja schon länger, wir verhalten uns wie ein altes Ehepaar.
Der Spruch kommt immer, wenn Leute irgendwas zu zu zweit machen.
Ja könnten einem halt nicht eine glückliche Ehe.
Die wissen auch gar nicht, was eine glückliche Ehe wirklich ausmacht. Richtig. Ja, eben.
Richtig. Kann nicht immer nur alles schön sein.
Ja ist äh ist schon ist schon ganz gut, man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass man nicht in so mhm wie sagt man, in so Routinen verfällt.
Zum Beispiel wenn wir uns hier das jede Sendung gleich begrüßen.
So was würden wir ja nie tun.
Nee, das der rastet, der rostet da entwickeln wir uns die ganze Zeit neu.
Aber ist schon äh schon ähm wichtig, will jetzt nicht so einen Quatsch sagen wie man muss sich immer hinterfragen und irgendwie so im Zweifel stellen so was würden wir ja auch nicht tun.
Nein.
Aber ist schon.
Schwäche.
Irgendwie also zumindest beschäftigt mich manchmal so der Gedanke sag mal ist der ganze netzpolitische Kram für dich eigentlich noch interessant? Also es ist so so eine Frage die mir dieses Jahr wirklich durch den Kopf ging.
Schon ja ist ja eine Frage, wie man das so äh definiert, ja,
Aber ich habe auch gemerkt, wie sich meine Sichtweise auf die Dinge über die Zeit doch geändert hat,
also ne? Man hat ja früher dann auch äh sagen wir mal so recht impulsive äh kurzgefasste, klare,
Hier ist alles böse und da ist alles gut so und mit der Zeit lernt man die Welt so ein bisschen kennen und stellte dann ab und zu mal fest so mhm,
Ja schon, aber äh es gibt da Nuancen und die muss man in dieser Debatte dann auch äh diskutieren.
Also ich würde sagen, ich stelle mir weniger die Frage, äh ob ich das doch interessant finde, sondern ich frage mich, äh ist dieser ganze netzpolitische Kram gut für dich? Jetzt.
Für mich oder für dich?
Für mich. Ja, aber das äh sage ich mal jetzt äh nicht besonders erfreulich ist und ehrlich gesagt würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen.
Dass sich,
dass ich die Perspektiven geändert haben, sondern es hat sich auch einfach in den elf Jahren dieses,
weiterentwickelt, ja? Und Positionen, die man vielleicht,
vor 5 oder zehn Jahren noch mit äh sehr viel stärkerer WMs vertreten konnte. Ähm.
Sind vielleicht heute nicht mehr in der.
Wie soll man's halt nicht mehr in dem Ausmaß haltbar oder also oder erscheinen auch anders oder also die Welt ist vielleicht dann auch oder oder das Internet ist differenzierter geworden, ja? Nicht unbedingt die Perspektive, sondern auch die,
Das, was man sich anschaut. Ja, also das Objekt oder das Subjekt. Nicht nicht nur nicht nur wie man draufschaut, sondern es hat sich ja auch selber äh sehr geändert.
Ist ganz lustig. Neulich ähm erreichte mich eine Mail von einem alten Chaos Radiohörer, der durch seine Festplatte gegangen ist,
eine Datei entdeckt hat, die hieß Chaos Radio zwanzig. Punkt MP3,
und äh schrieb ganz begeistert, dass er äh offensichtlich eine Aufzeichnung von Chaos Radio zwanzig gefunden hat, davon gibt's nämlich keine Aufzeichnung.
Und ich sah die Mail und dachte mir so, hm das kommt ja irgendwie bekannt vor so und dann habe ich aber bevor ich irgendwie groß weiter recherchiert habe, habe ich einfach mal in die Datei mal so reingehört, weil irgendwie schöner, einfach mal so gucken, okay was.
Bestimmt noch nie, also ich habe wahrscheinlich auch die anderen alle noch nie so richtig nachgehört, aber ich habe dann einfach mal reingehört, es waren Intro, das war eine Sendung, wo ich dabei war,
Und sie ist gefahren durch das Internet.
Es handelte sich nicht um Chaosradio zwanzig, sondern um Klaus Radio neun,
er hatte es aus irgendwelchen Gründen unter 20 abgespeichert,
und ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, weil dann habe ich dann dachte ich auch so,
Hat sie das schon mal. Dann bin ich so in meine Mail gegangen und festgestellt dieselbe Mail hat er mir vor fünf Jahren auch schon mal geschickt,
die gefunden zu haben, hat sich aber daran wahrscheinlich nicht mehr erinnert. Absolut verständlich.
Auf jeden Fall fing die Sendung irgendwie an und äh nach dem kurzen Vorstellungs äh Mythos, damals noch mit Johnny Häusler und so,
Wundern irgendwie alle von Johnny äh gefragt, wo sie denn so die Gefahren im Internet sehen und ich war dann ganz überrascht von meiner Antwort. Ich hoffe, ich kriege das jetzt noch richtig äh erinnert. Ich hab's mir jetzt nicht wirklich.
Deine größte Sorge oder ist irgendein Milliardär, eine Kommunikationsplattform kauft?
Nee, ähm ich,
nochmal nachhören, aber jetzt so aus meiner Erinnerung habe ich gesagt, ich habe die Größe,
ist hier die größte Gefahr oder weiß nicht, ob ich Gefahr gesagt habe oder ich habe die größten Bedenken da drin, dass die Leute irgendwie nicht damit klarkommen,
ähm dass Sie äh jetzt eine Kommunikation haben, die es nicht mehr erfordert, sich so Face to Face,
gegenüber zu sitzen. Äh ich hab's etwas geschickter formuliert in dem Moment, aber das war sozusagen meine meine Befürchtung. Und ich fand das,
Ich war ein bisschen überrascht von meiner eigenen äh Perspektive damals. Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt nicht äh lange verbracht die ganze Sendung nachzuholen, aber werde ich vielleicht nochmal tun, kann ich euch auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Ist übrigens erschienen am achtundzwanzigsten ach,
neunzehnhundertsechsundneunzig. Das jetzt acht.
20 Jahre, ja. Gott, ich bin alt.
Ihr werdet allein der der Introtext ist lustig, das Internet ist da. Rund zwei Jahre nachdem die Öffentlichkeit auf das Wissenschaftlernetz wirklich aufmerksam wurde, hat sich der Hype emanzipiert und jede denkbare gesellschaftliche Instanz denkt darüber nach
wie sie sich ihre Aktivitäten in das Internet erweitern lassen können. Home Banking, Telefoning und Cybersex sind in aller Munde und im Einzelnen kann schon Angst und Bagge werden.
Televoting? Das äh das Erste, was ihnen eingefallen ist.
Das ist das, was wir oder wahrscheinlich ich sogar damals in diesen Text reingeschrieben habe und das waren so die Sachen, die so rumgehypet wurden. Ja, ja.
Nicht nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern,
so im Verhältnis zueinander waren, aber Homepage ging, da gab's ja auch schon vorher und äh würde ich sagen, hat auch nach wie vor also Homepaking, bin ich sehr dafür,
hat sie war schon immer die Killer-App schon immer. Ich habe schon auf auf BTX gemacht und fand's geil. So in 80ern und so und Cyber Sex,
Ja, ne, ist irgendwie na ja, also na ja, kann man so also nicht vielleicht das, was jetzt die Leute so dachten mit den Brillen und so.
Nicht also nicht nicht in der Diadischen Konstellation so in den eher so ein so ein singuläres äh Vergnügen ja.
Tele-Voting, also und es sind ja auch alle so Sachen, wo so äh ähm Befürchtungen dranhängen, ne, also Homebänken, so Sicherheit, Geld und so, ist ja real, Porno überall und Telefonding. Ich meine, das Thema ist irgendwie auch nicht durch. Wir haben jetzt äh morgen
Morgen, heute ist Dienstag der achte nee heute. Heute sind die die Midterms äh Wahlen in den USA.
Wo ja dann und wenn du auf die letzten Wahlen schaust womit hat Trump es versucht,
mit äh die Wahlcomputer waren gefälscht.
Ganz lustig, das war auch immer eine unserer,
na ja wie auch immer, ich will mich jetzt hier auch nicht erst in unserer Damos äh feiern äh lassen, sondern diese Gefahren sind da und das Verhältnis dazu ist äh so eine Sache und wenn man halt so einen Podcast macht, zumindest mal auf das Thema wieder zurückzukommen,
Denk ich muss man sich immer fragen okay also interessiert mich das noch?
Aber auch interessiert das was ich zu sagen habe dazu jemanden noch? Also habe ich sozusagen haben wir auch substanziell etwas dazu beizutragen und ich denke solange man das noch.
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus.
Ich sage nur so so lange.
Mir vor der Sendung sagen.
Ich sage ja nur, solange die Antwort darauf ja ist, das muss ja nicht so sein. Aber solange wir das glauben.
Oder solange die Antwort darauf mit ja anfängt. So ja also.
Schon irgendwie.
Ja, ja nee.
Ja aber verstehst du was ich meine? Also das ist schon dieses man muss,
sich zumindest selbst so weit hinterfragen, dass man äh nicht einfach,
sich selbst einfach nur für das relevanteste Filterelement im Internet hält, sondern einfach äh auch immer wieder einen Schritt zurück macht und auch die eigenen Positionen mal ein bisschen,
abklopft. So und da halt,
Weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das auch so ein Trend, dass man dann mehr abwägt, während man früher alles schwarz weiß gesehen hat und jetzt sind überall nur Graustufen. Man kommt nicht mehr zum,
klaren Schluss. Das ist äh auf jeden Fall etwas, was so ein Teil des Spiels ist,
ja. Soviel dazu.
Wie wird's jetzt die Kurve zu den Spenden kriegen.
Sagen wir Tim, also.
Ich find's, ich find's immer interessant zu sehen, wie so andere also ich meine es gibt ja durchaus so ein Teil im Internet, so der der dieses Ding mit der Werbung wirklich zu gnadenlos durchzieht so. Facebook und so. Mhm.
Weißt du was jetzt, was mir jetzt auffällt? Was mir jetzt auffällt? Tim,
Ich hätte, ich wollte dir einen Vorschlag machen. Ich würde, also wenn wir in Logbuch Netzpolitik Werbung schalten, ne, dann nee pass auf, das ist dann könnten wir mit dem Geld könnten wir denn Werbung für unseren Podcast machen?
Um um dann noch mehr.
Platz vorbei,
stehen da irgendwie Plakatwerbung für Podcast.
Da habe ich früher mal drüber nachgedacht, das wollte ich tatsächlich mal machen. Habe ich dann aber sein gelassen.
Finanziert mit Werbung. Also ich dieses Werbezeug, ich werde da also,
Ich äh werde da rappelig. Also ich kann das auch nicht mehr haben. Das ist genau der Grund, dass ich nicht fernsehe,
Es ist tatsächlich äh ohne jetzt zu benennen, aber auch Podcasts, die vielleicht längere Zeit ich auf der guten Seite verortet habe, die dann jetzt auch noch dieses äh ach, da gibt's sogar ein wunderschönes ähm
Das hat mir letztens eine erklärt. Da war ich bei einer Veranstaltung, da habe ich eine Person kennengelernt, die für einen Podcast Vermarkter arbeitet,
und ähm ähm ja Native Voice Advertising oder sowas heißt das.
Klingt so, als hätte, könnte es das sein.
Native äh Native Host, Advertising oder irgendwie so was heißt das, ne,
meinte dann so, ja äh äh also ich vermarkte Podcast, wenn man hier Native Host Advertimes ich so, ja ähm,
Ähm finde ich ähm finde ich gehört verboten. Ja warum?
So, ich sehe ja, weil ist Schleichwerbung, haben wir aus guten Gründen auch verboten und diese ganzen Influencer mit ihrer Schleichwerbung und die Menschen, die das Vertrauen, was sie mit dem Podcast bei ihren Hörerinnen aufbauen, verkaufen,
dieses Vertrauen verraten, das gehört verboten. Muss eine andere Person einsprechen, äh muss gekennzeichnet sein, halte ich, also finde ich, finde ich gehört verboten und wenn man's nicht verbietet, dann muss man sich's wenigstens verbitten.
Aber Netive damit meinen sie doch nur, die Hosts sprechen es selber.
Sprechen's selber ein. Ja ja genau, aber das ist ja ich merk's ja selber, dass ich die ganze Zeit überlege bei den US-Podcaster da den nehme ich das nicht so übel, aber ich denke auch die ganze Zeit, wann ich endlich meine Serverfarm zu Linnot umziehe, weil Marco,
hostet. Oh, tolle Supporter der Show. Nein, ich finde das total daneben und das habe ich der guten Frau auch gesagt und dann ähm,
Noch so ein bisschen was vom Podcast erklären, bis ich dann irgendwann so meinte so.
Ja.
Ja ja. Aber sie hatte auch verstanden, dass ich da eigentlich also es wäre jetzt quasi überhaupt nicht.
Also es ist sehr ist sehr interessant, vor allem ich habe ja ich habe wirklich die Geschichte, wie sich das so entwickelt hat damals auch live mitbekommen. Du hast ja so der erste richtige äh Podcaster war nein.
Du. In USA meinst du?
Ähm na ja, tatsächlich war er damals glaube ich ähm noch in ähm in Europa, als fällt mir seinen scheiß Namen nie ein. Ähm na?
Hört man den heute noch?
Adam Curry. Adam Curry, auf den geht ja auch diese also der hat durchaus was beigetragen, ja.
Öfter geht ja auch die Wurst.
Tja, war ja auch der erste Adam halt, ne? Ähm äh nie gehört? Adam Curry, sagt ihr.
Name sagt mir was, aber.
Er ist mittlerweile auch in diese libertäre irgendwie Krypto äh Bubble und macht irgendwie Podcast.
Wenn wir da landen, ne.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ein echtes Problem, ne. Der macht dann so, ja, jetzt hier Podcasting 20 RSS, Extensions und so. Und dann bauen wir da noch Bitcoin mit ein. Leute, echt. Aber was ich ihm zugute halten muss, er hat am Anfang diese ganze Podcast-Geschichte
echt nach vorne gebracht, also wirklich richtig gut nach vorne gebracht. Das fing nämlich damit an, dass er überhaupt so,
Die treibende Kraft war, den ersten wirklichen Podcast-Client zu äh entwickeln,
und hat so seine Hörer irgendwie verrückt gemacht, weil er war auch so YouTube, äh Youtube.
Früher MTV Moderator.
Sagen ah okay jetzt kommt's mal ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ja, aber so, ne, ist aber so was Ähnliches. Und ähm.
Auch auch äh die ganze Zeit flackern und Werbung.
Egal, äh also jetzt mal ganz unbenommen, wie er sich irgendwie entwickelt hat. Also er ist einfach ein hervorragender ähm,
sage ich mal. Also er hat Ansprache, er hat irgendwie Schmiss, er hat irgendwie gute Ideen, er redet,
so das war alles extrem unterhaltsam, was er damals gemacht hat und er ist halt total besessen gewesen von dieser Idee
Software liest den RSS-Feed, nimmt die Datei und schreibt sie aufn iPod. Also dieses wirkliche Tatsächliche auf den Al.
Ja ja, ich habe auch. Ich habe auch äh Podcasts äh früher, ne, wenn man das schon mal von früher reden. Auf meinem iPod gehört und das musste ich vors iTunes da dran sünken. Mit dem 30pol-Stecker.
Genau. Aber bevor es das gab, bevor es in iTunes drin war, hat er quasi die allererste Version äh gemacht hat. Da er selber aber kein Programmierer ist, hat er sich sozusagen Leute gesucht. Er hat einfach die Idee.
Media in Closia Tech in RSS mit einzubauen. Das gab's schon.
Nein, nein, das gab's schon, weil das das hat schon ähm in den RSS-Standard mit reingemacht. Also der ist, sagen wir mal, der eigentliche,
Erfinder der Auslieferungs oder der Darreichungsmethode, aber dieses konkrete, die Lücke schließen, ein Stück Kot nimmt das und
tut es auch konkret auf einen iPod drauf, damit du's dann da hören kannst. Dann gab's halt erst mal keine Software und er hat das quasi
gestartet und äh da ist dann so eine etwas kribbelige Jawa-Software, die irgendwie aufm MAC lief, war nicht schön, war auch nicht toll, aber sie sie lief, ja, sie funktionierte.
Ja aber.
Und damit diese Programmierer, die sich darum gekümmert haben, damit die was hatten, damit die immer erst mal.
Der einen Podcast gemacht.
Die brauchen ja einen Podcast mit dem sie testen können. Hat er dafür einen Podcast gestartet und der hieß The Daily Sourscode.
Unser Dailys Horsecoat war sozusagen erstmal nur so ein Testpodcast und das ist dann aber auch wirklich sein Haupt-Podcast.
Gewesen. Ich weiß, gibt's gibt's die eigentlich noch? Glaube nicht mehr. Äh mittlerweile ist er mit diesem anderen Vogel egal. Auf jeden Fall Daily Source Cood war wirklich eine fantastische Sendung und ich habe das äh gerne gehört,
und dann fing er halt irgendwann an auch diese ganze,
ähm also Werbung in dem Sinne hatte er nicht in diesem Podcast aber er hat,
wie sagt man so schön auf Englisch,
Also er hatte so so Segmente drin äh,
mit eigenen Clips, zum Beispiel gab's äh so ein Segment the metural sexual moment,
über Rasiercreme irgendwie für Männer und so weiter unterhalten hat und immer schön reingerannt hat und dann aber auch immer so durchhängen ließ so,
Ja Leute, das funktioniert eigentlich total super, ne? Und wie darüber könnt ihr halt auch irgendwie Werbung auch gut funktionieren? Und ich würde sagen, man kann das schon auf ihn zurückführen, dass dieses die Werbung funktioniert eigentlich am besten von den Radio Host selber gesprochen.
Ja natürlich, also aber aus dem Grund halt.
Ich sage nur da aber so hat es so ein bisschen so seine Entwicklung genommen und ich erinnere mich halt jetzt noch dran, dass es da ist. Trotzdem, und da sagst du halt, was goldrichtig ist und das empfinde ich halt auch genauso, weil ich einfach,
Also ich habe schon Beklemmungen, wenn ich überhaupt nur monologisch in in meinen Podcast reinspreche, um nur mal eine Ansage zu machen. Aber Werbung hat halt immer so ein bisschen was,
Das Gefühl, ich rede gar nicht selbst. So eine so eine so ein so ein Geist zieht in mich ein und lässt mich reden. So wie wie so in so einem besessenen Film, so als müsste jetzt gleich der Exorzist kommen,
mir irgendwie den Werbe den Werbegeist aus.
Wenn du hier irgendwo Werbung.
Exorzieren. Der muss dir keine Sorgen machen.
Das ist gut, danke.
Nee, das das.
Ein wahrer Freund, Linus.
Fit hier, speist du aber hier aus allen äh Öffnungen äh Galle. Also der der ähm also die ähm das Modell mit der Werbung,
Es ist ja tatsächlich es ist ein Erfolgsmodell, ja? Also was wir was ähm und ich habe das hier glaube ich spreche das immer wieder an dieses Buch von Tim Wood, die Attention Mergens. Ja also das äh das Sammeln von Aufmerksamkeit auf einen Punkt, ja, Menschen gucken dahin
ähm diese Aufmerksamkeit an andere Leute abzugeben,
ist ein Geschäftsmodell, was überall funktioniert, ne? Hier liegt ein Spiegel aufm Tisch, also das äh das Wochenmagazin der Spiegel. Kannst du eigentlich an einer beliebigen Stelle aufmachen, ist da Werbung drin, ja?
Ähm,
Fernsehen zum beliebigen Zeitpunkt anmachen kommt Werbung. Du kannst in den App Store gucken, kommt Werbung, du kannst in in jede scheiß soziale Netzwerk gucken, wenn du äh es kommt Werbung und alles wird irgendwie mit mit äh Werbung zugeballert. Netflix,
eines großes Feature es war keine Werbung zu haben. Haben wir jetzt auch irgendwie so ein äh ähm.
Low-Level hier, wo sie die dann auch noch Werbung reinballern. Und ähm,
Das das mag ja vielleicht irgendwie bei Fernsehserien oder so was sogar noch halbwegs gehen aber in diesem, wenn ich eine Sache feststelle beim Podcasting,
Ist es, dass die Menschen auch von einer spezifischen ähm,
Aufgrund der vielen Stunden, die sie da den Leuten beim Monolog oder Dialog ähm zuhören,
eine eine Bindung aufbauen und was ich öfter feststelle oder was oder nicht eine Bindung, aber in einem Bezug äh eine eine Beziehung.
Aufbauen und weil's mir immer wieder erzählt wird von Menschen ist auch, dass sie,
mich irgendwie irgendwo treffen, kennenlernen oder so und sagen krass, ich,
Kenne dich seit so vielen Jahren und du bist mir so vertraut und ich muss stehe dir aber gerade gegenüber als jemand,
dir völlig fremd ist, ne? Und dieses, dieses Vertrauen,
abzugeben,
ähm und an äh und anderen an andere zu verkaufen, ja und zu sagen, hier pass auf, du kannst dieses Vertrauen äh mit missbrauchen, um um dein Produkt zu platzieren. Finde ich irgendwie grundsätzlich nicht okay.
Und äh also äh ich finde, es geht auch ich septe auch eine Abneigung gegen, wenn irgendwie äh wie heißt dieser, durchgeknallte äh Rapper da, yay yay we.
Alle durchgeknallt, aber du meinst wahrscheinlich den, ja.
Das war das Beste. Ich habe glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, ob ich in meinem Leben schon mal ein Adidas Produkt besessen habe, ne. Aber ich werde jetzt welche kaufen, weil ich das so gut finde, dass die den für sein antisemitisches Geschwurbel da jetzt einfach mal rausgeworfen haben, ja.
Lang genug gedauert.
Ja okay, aber äh habe ich nicht verfolgt, ja. Aber deswegen, ich finde das tatsächlich ein äh Modell, das ich persönlich,
äh sehr,
schwierig äh für diese Podcast annehmen würde, ja? Ähm gleichzeitig ist es nahezu unmöglich, sich überhaupt noch irgendwo zu bewegen, ohne dass irgendwo jemand lauert, der oder die halt ähm
was weiß ich, das Event sponsort ähm irgendwie
äh versucht von allem, was gut ist, alles was cool ist ähm irgendwo mit reinzukommen. So komm
wir wir sponsorn euch äh die Shirts, äh wenn wir da noch ein Logo drauf machen dürfen, kommen wir äh wir wir bezahlen euch viel für den Podcast, wenn wir am Ende sagen dürfen, dass die Leute, wenn ihr am Ende sagt, dass dass euch der neue Mercedes gefällt oder was auch immer für einen Quatsch ist, ich finde das bedauerlich.
Ja
Aber jetzt werden natürlich äh viele sofort einwenden und sagen, ja aber wenn ich denn doch gerne Podcasting machen möchte und ich möchte gerne dafür viel Zeit haben, dann muss ich ja auch damit Geld verdienen.
Und äh ihr seid ja schon irgendwie immer dabei und seid ja sowieso total äh berühmt und und so weiter äh,
Für euch funktioniert ja vielleicht ein Spendenmodell, aber für kleine,
funktioniert das nicht und wenn die da halt ein bisschen Werbung machen, dann dann geht sich das aus. Das ist,
Ein Einwand, der immer kommt, der auch nicht ganz.
Aber ein kleiner Podcast, den äh den der wenige Hörerinnen und Hörer hat. Ähm der wird ja auch keine Werbekunden finden.
Dann gibt's ja heutzutage dann eben diese ganzen Distributier, die ich hier über Dollarplattform und via äh,
bauen dir die Werbung dann hintenrum ein. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob das dann im Einzelnen immer funktioniert oder nicht, aber ich sage nur, das ist so ein Argument, dass sozusagen diese dieser Mitverkauf der Aufmerksamkeit. Ich halte das trotzdem für falsch, ja, aber
Aber das das ist sozusagen auch wie,
viele dann argumentieren und ich kann das auch nachvollziehen, dass sie so argumentieren. Und wenn sie für sich erstmal keinen anderen Weg,
sehen.
Ja ich äh ach ich.
Ich will den die also es darf ja auch sowieso jeder machen. Jede alle können das machen wie sie wollen und ich kann ähm ich bin einfach da und kann entscheiden, ob ich mir das anhöre oder nicht, ja. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die ähm,
alles auf einmal machen. Ballern dich mit Werbung zu, verlange Geld, äh.
Und Abo.
Abo und was noch nicht alles so, ne, da fragt man sich eigentlich, ob die vor lauter Geld noch einen Podcast äh hinkriegen können. Okay. Ich äh persönlich habe ähm für mich nach wie vor den Fokus, dass ich äh.
Ähm durch durch tägliche oder beinahe tägliche Arbeit äh bei Geld verdiene und diese Podcasts aus Spaß mache.
Ist schön. Ich mache den auch aus Spaß, aber äh ist auch meine tägliche Arbeit sozusagen. Das mal mehr, mal mal weniger und für mich war ähm,
Eigentlich wegen dieser generellen ähm.
Sagen, dieses Unwohlsein, was ich was ich sozusagen mit mit Werbung,
und so Seelenverkäufern an sich habe, war das für mich nie eine Option. So und ich habe halt gestartet und habe halt gesagt,
Mir ist erstmal egal, ich denke jetzt nicht über Businessmodelle nach,
sondern probier's einfach mal und guck mal, was dabei rauskommt, weil ich will ja sowieso gerade nichts anderes tun und äh kennst mich ja wahrscheinlich. Ich kann ja immer nur das tun, was ich gerade will und wenn ich irgendwas nicht will, dann mache ich's mache ich's nicht.
Ich habe auch ich habe auch irgendwie insgesamt den Eindruck, dass wir vielleicht die falschen Typen sind um äh Businessmodelle zu sprechen, so vorsichtig.
Absolut.
Hey, wir haben Business-Hotel. Ja, okay. Gut, wir nicht.
Na oder vielleicht doch.
Wofür brauchst du das denn?
Na ja, du brauchst es halt, um die Kosten äh zu decken, ne. Also ich merke das ja immer, wenn die Serverrechnungen kommen und so. Also ist ja äh ist ja nicht nicht so, dass man das jetzt so heutzutage im Internet alles äh komplett,
kostenlos machen kann, beziehungsweise wenn du's kostenlos machst, bist du halt auch wieder schon irgendjemand anderes Produkt.
Das muss natürlich auf jeden Fall äh verhindert werden. Also ich bin soweit ganz zufrieden und ähm ja insofern Leute,
ähm müssen wir uns wollen wir unsere jährliche Danksagung äh von uns äh bringen?
Um äh ja die Wertschätzung auszudrücken, die äh in der Unterstützung, die äh ihr dieser Unternehmung hier äh gewährleistet,
jetzt habe ich den Satz zu lang gemacht und weiß nicht, wie ich ihn zu Ende bringen soll, Punkt.
So verlegen sind wir.
Sind wir.
Ähm nein, also natürlich äh Spaß beiseite. Es ist,
es ist auch sehr schön zu sehen, dass wir mit diesem Podcast natürlich auch,
kleines äh Einkommen bestreiten. Es ist äh sehr erfreulich immer, wenn wir Unterstützung bekommen,
viele äh Leute in den Kommentaren, viele Leute schreiben auch einfach mal persönliche Mails, was sich auch immer freut oder,
lassen sich andere äh persönliche Wege einfallen, uns eine Freude zu machen, aber äh die einfachste äh Möglichkeit,
ne sind, also einmalige große Beträge sind super, wiederkehrende große Beträge sind um einiges besser,
Kontonummer und äh demnächst äh äh wenn der wenn äh dieser dieser eiskalte Winter äh vorüber ist ähm äh planen wir auch mal wieder ein äh Event zu machen.
Genau.
Kann ich nicht mehr hören Tim. Ich kann jetzt nicht mehr hören, ey,
Ich kann es ich kann es wirklich nicht mehr heulen. Ich werde dich ein, ich ich werde dich am Ende für alles äh
äh ungemach, was dieser Welt hier äh äh in letzter Zeit passiert, verantwortlich machen,
du das schon irgendwie in den in den noch nicht 20ern beschrieben hast und als die Pandemie vorbei war, fingst du wieder an von den goldenen 20ern zu reden
jetzt schau wo wir sind. Jetzt haben wir äh äh jetzt haben wir Pandemie und Krieg.
Gucke mal, die Welt ist ja sozusagen eine Summe aus tausend Sachen, ja. Man muss auch schon ab und zu mal eine Furiertanzugation drauflegen. Es gibt da auch Wellen, die die andere Richtung zeigen. Man muss sich halt auch drauf konzentrieren.
Habe ich gestern schönen Gruß an Daniel, äh der genau das gleiche Gespräch geführt hat, auch nicht konnte mich auch nicht überzeugen, dass das grade gute Zeiten gäbe. Kann ich einfach nicht messen. Kann ich nicht feststellen. Tut mir leid.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist äh ist ja sozusagen ein Messproblem, ja. Also wir stehen da wahrscheinlich einfach nicht die entsprechenden Messgeräte zu.
Also wir äh freuen uns sehr über alle, die uns bereits unterstützen. Wir freuen uns auch sehr über alle, die sich jetzt noch neu entscheiden können, uns äh,
erstmalig äh und im Idealfall auch dauerhaft zu unterstützen und ähm ja und umso länger ihr das tut, umso besser ist es. Es ist halt einfach,
beruhigendste Art und Weise der Finanzierung, weil man einfach immer sehen kann, so aha okay, läuft und so kommen wir ja voran.
Damit sind wir beim Feedback, oder?
Beim Feedback.
Ja oder?
Oh ja, das war auch gut. Sehr viel äh Feedback, was ich äh mit unserer Sendung als solcher beschäftigt hat. Erstmal,
Kam der Hinweis, der Statuscode vierhundertvierundvierzig ist übrigens No Response von keiner Antwort.
Hat mich daran erinnert, dass ich total vergessen habe, noch zu schauen, ob wir denn schon wieder im äh offiziellen Zahlenbereich sind und immerhin äh konnte ich feststellen,
sind wir noch nicht. Also bis 450 gibt's noch keine offiziellen Statuskurse, aber es gibt halt diese inoffiziellen, die also an verschiedenen Stellen äh benutz,
zum Beispiel das mit dem,
und ähm oder also nicht das mit dem T-Pod, das ist ja so ein richtiger Joke, aber es gibt halt so welche, ne, Leute nehmen sich halt irgendwelche Zahlen und benutzen die für irgendetwas. Nur Response ist so ein Ding und ähm ja, insofern äh hatte ich so kurz Herzkasper, aber,
nach nach der Sendung 450 müssen wir dann wieder aufpassen.
Da kommt übrigens der der nach der Sendung 450 vorgestellte Code. Ich weiß nicht, ob der offiziell, da gibt's, glaube ich, ein RFC zu. Der ist jünger als Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Mhm, stimmt.
Weiß ich, dass wir den die Einführung damals hier besprochen haben.
Haben, genau.
Nächstes Feedback.
Genau äh.
Otto meinte ähm hm zum Intro der letzten Sendung. Bei der hier üblichen Nachrichtenlage kommen die satanischen Botschaften auch bei normalem Vorwärts-Abspielen deutlich zur Geltung.
Das lassen wir mal so stehen, ne? Ja, genau. Genau.
Zahlen gut. Der Satan zahlt gut für die Geheimbotschaften, die wir hier mit reinmachen, sonst könnten wir, sonst könnten wir irgendwo von müssen wir auch leben.
Genau und Speaking auf Satan äh Kai schreibt, Interviewer, Linus auf einer Skala von 1 bis zehn, wie angepisst bist du, dass Tim den Unterschied zwischen Abberufung und Untersagung nicht versteht? Linus ja,
Daraufhin Holzgriffs, ist aber langsam schon seltsam, in welchem unangemessenen Ton Linus immer häufiger mit Tim redet.
Daraufhin bildet sich das Beschwerdeamt. Ja, andererseits auch sehr offensichtlich und so eine im positiven Sinne und Professionalität ist auch sympathisch. Hoffen wir, dass es nicht endet wie beim Aufwachen-Podcast.
Christian, ich denke die feindliche Übernahme steht kurz bevor. Linus kauft den Laden, schmeißt Tim raus und macht auch seinen P eins Spotify Exclusive, während ich das hier schreibe, ist Tim mutmaßlich schon freigestellt.
Ja okay, also danke für das Feedback. Kommen wir zur ersten Meldung. BSI-Präsident,
der Präsident des BSI-Timm, er ist es weiterhin ja, der geht gegen die Untersagung äh seiner Dienstgeschäfte vor.
Nur wenn du das jetzt endlich anerkennst, ich habe wirklich die Schnauze voll, ey. Den ganzen Tag irgendwelche unqualifizierten Widerworte.
Ja. Es ist einfach mal eine Selbstzweifel. Die kommen immer wieder durch.
Elon Musk kauft ja Twitter nicht, habe ich gesagt.
Ja, haste gesagt, hast du nicht so richtig äh nicht so richtig gelegen, ne? Jetzt hat er's gekauft.
Ich glaube, da ich ich bleibe dabei, dass es nicht seine Absicht war.
Ich glaube, dass es zumindest zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt nicht mehr seine Absicht war, aber es dann halt zu spät war, um noch zurückzurudern und jetzt muss er irgendwie damit leben.
Und ich muss sagen es ist um einiges unterhaltsamer als ich dachte,
Filter kauft.
Also bisher.
Äh also bisher unglaublich unterhaltsam. Ähm also Alter, was ist da.
Vierundvierzig.
Hatte er nicht. Das Unternehmen twittert jetzt erstmal mit 13 Milliarden äh Euro Schulden belastet,
Also es ist ja, das war ja das hat also wenn du Geld hast.
Dann kriegst du mehr Geld relativ kostenlos dazu.
Deswegen ist es ja auch so dramatisch arm zu sein, weil man sich das echt kaum leisten kann, im Gegensatz zu reich sein.
Ähm was er, also er hat natürlich jetzt irgendwie er hat irgendwelche Kredite aufgenommen, das heißt, er hat nicht es gibt jetzt nicht eine Überweisung von 44 Milliarden Euro äh US-Dollar,
von Elon Musk Konto. Ähm an Twittern, sondern es gibt eine eine äh Reihe an Krediten,
die er irgendwo äh bekommen hat, irgendwo Saudi-Arabien dann irgendwelche Teilhaberschaften und was nicht alles,
ja irgendwelche Quatsch so ne und dann hat der natürlich auch hat er wahrscheinlich Teste Aktien verkauft oder Berlin ähm und das Unternehmen Twitter selber hat auf jeden Fall jetzt auch 13 Milliarden.
Euro Schulden ja das ist natürlich ganz praktisch weil wenn die ganze Scheiße untergeht muss er die 13 Milliarden schon mal nicht bezahlen weil äh,
die Schulden hat ja das Unternehmen. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der diese Tricks gemacht hat, aber er hat sich eine,
Er hat einen finanziellen Trick durchgeführt, der dazu führt, dass er jetzt der Eigner äh von Twitter ist und ähm.
Und und damit ist halt Twitter auch von der Börse runter. Also es gibt keine Aktien mehr. Es ist jetzt private. Muss auch keine Zahlen veröffentlichen. Muss irgendwie keine Quarterlehre.
Macht er aber.
Aber nicht nicht nach irgendwelchen vorgeschriebenen Regeln.
Jetzt machen was er will. Ähm das hat er der Welt mitgeteilt, indem er ähm in einem in einem also wirklich bewundernswerten Anflug von Humor äh getwittert hat, äh I'm a twitter HQ, let that's think in,
ein ein Waschbecken da reingetragen hat, weil Waschbecken ist ein Zink ähm ja kann man jetzt also kann man,
also,
Ich sage mal, ist jetzt so ein Humorniveau, was ich äh schon auch höher gesehen habe. Aber immerhin, man hat gemerkt, er fand's lustig und also er hat's er hat sich auf jeden Fall sehr beömmelt und dann hat er auch seine Freude daran gehabt. Ich meine.
Er ist zumindest bereit überhaupt darüber einen Witz zu.
Ja.
Ist schon mal gut. Humor ist immer trotzdem lacht. Ich meine, er hat sich sechs sechs Monate eigentlich damit beschäftigt kein gutes Haar an dem Laden zu lassen, den er jetzt kauft, ja und das und und,
Trägt dein Waschbecken rein, was ich meine immerhin. Vielleicht äh so bei Amazon hätten sie sich gefreut, äh wenn sie ein Waschbecken kriegen so, aber okay.
Dann äh geht er rein und ähm feuert erstmal die komplette Chefetage und den Verwaltungsrat,
Und ähm dann irgendwie unter anderem so schon zu Beginn irgendwie so Teams, die sich äh Algorithmenanalyse auf Rassismus und sonstige Dinge halt wichtige Dinge machen.
Alle erstmal rausgeworfen und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das alles noch hinkriege, äh was der was er jetzt in den wenigen Tagen ähm alles so,
Angeleiert hat. Also der der.
Zunächst, ach so genau, dann kurz nachdem er das Ding übernommen hat, ich glaube so kam dann einem ein ein Tweet, indem er eben gesagt, zu dir Advertisers,
Sagt so, ja hey, ich will ja hier einen Ort der äh freien Rede schaffen.
Aber nicht notwendigerweise, das soll jetzt nicht hier der Höllenschlund werden, das ist ja völlig klar, also ihr könnt ruhig weiter hier werben, da merkst du schon so oh,
jetzt ist ihm halt klar geworden,
dass er jetzt seine sechs Monate Twitter ist die größte Scheiße aufm Planeten, kaufe ich nicht alles voller Bots, Schrott hier. Das sind das jetzt,
Wieder gut machen muss und es stellt sich raus, dass halt äh Twitter tatsächlich ähm massenhaft Anzeigenkunden,
verloren hat und zwar nicht unbedingt erst seitdem das übernommen hat, sondern ähm auch ja in einem Kontext vorher ähm.
Weil und das habe ich jetzt auch nur aus einem Tweet mir erklären lassen, dass diese Online-Firmen,
üblicherweise mit starken Discounts so einmal im Jahr,
größeren Teil ihrer Werbeplätze verkaufen. Das heißt, die gibt's dann eben im Dutzend billiger und dann wird irgendwie so äh üblicherweise liegt der Wert bei ähm,
Twitter wohl zwischen 600 und 900 Millionen, also zwischen 0,6 und einer 0,9 Milliarden ähm die sie,
schon,
im Voraus verkaufen für das Jahr und damit haben sie einfach eine garantierte Finanzierungspass, ähnlich jetzt wie die Metaebene. So und ähm.
Folgende Jahr einfach schon mal gut steht, ja?
Und dann gab's aber eine eine die sich nannte Stop the Deal und die hat ähm,
Einerseits ähm die kaufenden informiert und die großen Wärmenden ähm und hat die gebeten Twitter mal ein paar Fragen über ihre,
wie sie denn die Zukunft sehen, wenn Laden übernimmt, was denn der Plan ist, wie das denn da so aussieht. So und die konnten diese,
Antworten nicht geben und da du natürlich also das ist ja relativ verständlich, dass du halt als äh ne Werbe,
Platzkäuferin, da sind ja sicherlich auch irgendwelche äh wie wie Broker bei, die dann halt einfach mal Twitter-Werbung kaufen, um die nachher teurer zu verkaufen, dass sie sich alle denken, na ja, wenn ich nicht weiß, wie dieser Laden in drei Wochen aussieht, geschweige denn im halben Jahr,
dann kaufe ich diese Werbeflächen vielleicht lieber nicht und kaufe vielleicht da, wo es wo ich zumindest weiß, dass es dass der Laden noch,
im halben Jahr ziemlich genauso langweilig ist, wie es jetzt ist, zum Beispiel Facebook oder so.
Und äh da hat Twitter unglaublich wenig äh verkauft. Das heißt, Twitter steht jetzt also Musk steht jetzt da mit seinem Twitter und diese ganze Unsicherheit, die er geschaffen hat.
Schlägt sich eben auch darin nieder, dass er jetzt gar nicht, dass er gar nicht die Werbeeinnahmen hat,
weil er eben die Unsicherheit über seine Übernahme äh so stark äh in den letzten Monaten beschrien hat.
Und die Werbeeinnahmen waren bei Twitter jetzt sowieso nicht so großartig und das ist halt die Haupteinnahmequelle.
Genau, 90 Prozent der Einnahmen, ja und wenn da halt mal äh wenn da die Hälfte wegfällt, dann äh hast du mehr als hast du die Hälfte deiner Einnahmen nicht mehr so ungefähr, ne?
Oder fast die Hälfte. Dann hat er ähm,
Haben jetzt eben mehrere sich eben von dieser Plattform zurückgezogen und er veröffentlichte ziemlich direkt danach so einen so einen Arschkriecherbrief, in dem er dann eben sagt, so ey hier egal, das wird alles super hier, total safe for safespace,
für Rassisten und und Werbende so und.
Ja.
Und ähm ja stellte sich raus, hat irgendwie nicht äh nicht überzeugt, ja und ähm,
Dann merkst du, wie er im weiteren Lauf äh Verlauf der Zeit offenbar immer mehr sein Waschbecken, dadurch twittert, trägt so von Büro zu Büro, wo ihm dann irgendwie so mal erklärt wird so ja willkommen,
Hier ist übrigens Twitter, so hast du jetzt gekauft und übrigens,
Ähm wir moderieren hier Content und so, damit du damit überhaupt noch irgendjemand hier ähm werben möchte. So,
und während er so durch Twitter läuft, so stelle ich mir das irgendwie vor. Was willst du auch sonst machen? Twittert er natürlich, ne,
und twittert so Ideen vor sich hin,
Und ich bleibe jetzt mal bei diesen Werbekundenstrang und twittert dann, ja ähm es wäre ja so, dass ähm Moment äh habe ich den.
Ist da die totale Jogg, der totale Jodog-Moment. Twitters, so yeah, you can by Twitter, so you can Twitter why you in Twitter.
Es ist wirklich äh genau, aber pass auf, dann twittert er so so sinngemäß.
Ja, also die Aktivist-Gruppen hätten jetzt Twitter das ganze Review weggenommen,
ja und ähm,
und obwohl sie alles versucht hätten, die zu ähm peasen, also äh so zu beruhigen ihn ähm ich warte die direkte Übersetzung von.
Das ist eine gute Übersetzung, in dem schon Text. Mhm.
Entgegenkommen, beruhigen, ähm so.
Und äh das müsste jetzt ein Ende haben. So, dann dann ähm antwortet ihm irgendwie ein ähm so ein was war der Hintergrund von dem Typen? Ein rechter,
Internetlobby ist. Mike Davis, der dann sagt, ey pass auf, ähm beleg doch einfach die, die hier die Werbeanzeigen grade kündigen,
Mit einem Gegenboykott. Du hast doch die Reichweite, denen's schaden,
Antwortet äh Elon Musk genau das wird passieren, wenn das jetzt nicht aufhört, dann gibt es ein firm nuklear name and shame.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, was was besser
was eine bessere Werbung für eine Plattform ist, als zu sagen, wenn du jetzt aufhörst, dann werde dann mache ich euch fertig, so färbt, wenn ihr bei uns die Werbeanzeigen kündigt, dann,
ich meine Reichweite, um eure, eurer Marke zu schädigen. So, da kann ich ich also.
Das sehe ich schon richtig wie ausgerechnet Elon Mastern, Volkswagen. Wie die Brand kaputthauen will auf Twitter. Da hat er noch.
Du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, dass natürlich jede Person, die über ein Werbebudget verfügt, sagt so Scheiße, Alter, so dass uns irgendwie so leise hier weg. Schalter noch ein bisschen Werbung, damit er's nicht merkt, aber ähm,
lass uns zusehen, dass wir hier wegkommen, ja? Ähm so das äh also da ist es sehr schön, aber also ich meine,
Äh wirklich ähm da merkt man dann schon, dass dem Typen auch.
Eine gewisse Reife fehlt, ja. Du kannst du kannst ja nicht äh es sei denn,
dein Ziel ist aber na gut, also ich meine vielleicht möchte er dieses Ding ja überhaupt nicht mehr über Werbung äh finanzieren. Er äh spuckt ja auch am laufenden Band Ideen raus, wie er den Laden monetarisieren könnte, ja? Was,
Bemerkung, genau der Grund ist, warum da gerade niemand wirkt, weil der weil der twittert und sagt, ja äh ähm ich habe mir überlegt,
Dieser blaue Haken, dieses blaue Hakensystem. Hier gibt's Leute, die haben blaue Haken und ich Tim hatte übrigens einen
Blauen Haken, musst du gleich mal erzählen. So, blauer Haken gibt es für veryfight Accounts. Da muss man irgendwie also ich hatte mal irgendwie die Möglichkeit, äh da hätte ich deinen Personalausweis hochladen müssen
Dann hätte der Account aber auch Linus Neumann heißen müssen. Ich wollte aber nicht, dass der Linus Neumann heißt. Also habe ich das nicht gemacht. So ähm relativ ein relativ,
klares System und diese blauen Haken waren durchaus begehrt, so weil sie irgendwie zeigen, ich bin wer, wenn man jetzt so einen blauen Haken hat. Also denkt sich Elon Musk voll geil.
Einen blauen Haken bekommen zu können, wird jetzt Teil einer Premium-Dienstleistung, diese Premium-Dienstleistung kostet 20 Dollar. Woraufhin irgendwie Leute, bist du bescheuert, ne? 20 Dollar?
Stephen King hat sich dazu geäußert.
Steven Key gesagt, nee, ist zu teuer und dann sagt Elon Musk, ja äh.
Hätte ich gesagt, das ist zu teuer. Er hat gesagt, äh wie fuck you und.
Ja ja ich wollte das jetzt ein bisschen diplomatisch außer. Also sagt Elon Mast, ja gut, dann eben acht.
Wobei zu dem Zeitpunkt war's wahrscheinlich eh schon klar, dass es äh äh diese acht Dollar sein sollen. Was äh in dem Zusammenhang, aber nach wie vor vollkommen unklar ist und man muss auch sagen, das was Elon Musk schreibt
antwortet, rausschreit und in so einem
permanenten, in so einer, in so einer Mental-Diaote eigentlich über diese diese Welt äh wirft, ja. Das ist natürlich bei ihm,
schon so ein Wesenswerk mal. Also das ist äh ich habe immer die ganze Zeit das Gefühl, wie nennt man so Leute, die die ganze Zeit ähm,
Schimpfworte rauswerfen müssen. Genau, er hat so eine so ein.
Die nennt man bei ihrem Namen, aber äh und die äh das das Phänomen heißt.
Nein, nein, nein. Das Phänomen, das meine ich ja auch. Ja ja genau. Also äh äh ja der der.
Oder man kann auch einfach Arschloch sagen. Also.
Ja, pass auf. Also, ne, also es gibt äh es gibt die Internet äh Etikett, aber es gibt halt auch die Internettourette und die hat die hatte ja irgendwie,
Er hat Internet-Tourette und äh ich habe das Gefühl, der der,
muss es teilweise tun und teilweise ist es auch wirklich echtes, wirkliches Trolling und teilweise ist es auch wirklich ein,
tiefer schwarzer Humor,
Eigentlich sehr schätzen kann, bin mir bloß immer nicht so ganz sicher, welcher von den Tweets ihr seid, die ich wirklich darauf zählt und welcher nicht. Aber einer davon auf jeden Fall. Weil man muss auch sagen, das Internet versteht auch keinen Spaß.
Also so also so so richtig nicht, ja klar Bilder, lustige Hunde und Katzen und ha ha ha und und wir lachen immer so einiges und guck mal, der ist gegen den Baum gelaufen und so, aber so richtig Humor
ähm ist schwierig, ne? Und und und es wird ja immer schon im Internet über das äh Ironietech gesprochen, ist ja so so ein Diskussions
ein Klassiker seit seit äh Anfang der neunziger Jahre, äh ja. Wurde auch glaube ich mehrfach versucht, da irgendeine Zeichenkombination zu finden, mit der man,
Dieser Satz war ironisch gemeint, funktioniert natürlich hinten und vorne nicht.
Habe ich's grade auch wieder so ein so ein so ein Fall von von irgend so einem Internet-Tourit.
Wie dein äh persönlicher Internetprophet äh vor 28 Jahren gesagt hat so, es wird schwierig, wenn die Leute irgendwie nur noch remote miteinander
kommunizieren und soll dann brechen die Sachen langsam auseinander. Und äh so ist es natürlich jetzt auch Elon Musk und und die Welt. Auf der anderen Seite, er ist natürlich halt auch einfach so ein
Rich Kit, ich meine, der war schon immer reich, der ist irgendwie aus einer südafrikanischen, die was war das? Diamantenmin oder irgend so ein Minengeschäft auf.
Was so richtig schön.
Der ist jetzt nicht ohne Spielgeld auf die Welt gekommen und äh das haben wir auch schon diskutiert, hat ja dann jetzt auch durchaus irgendwie interessante Projekte gemacht und zeigt in gewisser Hinsicht und jetzt das ist glaube ich jetzt auch der Test für ihn. Also wenn er es schafft,
das Ding irgendwie noch rumzureißen, also aus einem ohnehin wackeligen Produkt, was alle hassen, aber alle wollen,
Also nicht alle, aber die Leute, die auf Twitter sind, finden Twitter aber auch,
essentiell. Dann nehme ich mich selber äh nicht aus. Das ist definitiv das beste oder bestes schwieriges Wort. Für mich persönlich, dass,
Nützlichste soziale Netzwerk gewesen und eigentlich fast das Einzige, was ich wirklich benutze,
Facebook an, irgendwie Instagram verstehen nicht ähm und der ganze andere Videokram, die mir aus der Sonne TikTok äh ist einfach nix weich braucht Text und ähm.
Twitter hat ein, zwei Dinge erfunden bekommen,
hervorragend sind. Also ich sage nicht, Twitter hat's erfunden, weil Twitter hat ja fast nichts erfunden. Ja, also weder die Ednotation, noch irgendwie Menschens, noch äh also alles, was richtig geil ist, retweets und so weiter wurde ja von den Usern,
erfunden und wurde später, also die haben das alle irgendwie erstmal Prototyp und dann wurde es später von von Twitter ins Protokoll eingebaut,
Und das Einzige, was sie wirklich erfunden haben, was wirklich toll ist und was mich persönlich von Anfang an von Twitter vollständig eingenommen hat und wo ich denke, dass das ist einfach das ist das, was uns Twitter gegeben hat, ist das Follower-Modell.
Modell ist einfach genial. Und so einfach und äh so wunderbar gerade für diese ganzen asymmetrischen Beziehungen, die man auf dem Internet so äh
pflegt. Trotzdem, Internet ist technisch jetzt. Äh Twitter ist jetzt äh technisch nix.
Außergewöhnliches, da ist nicht viel Technologie drin, sondern es ist im Wesentlichen so eine Moderationshölle und der Versuch, irgendwie Geld zu verdienen und das funktioniert so na ja.
Das also äh das jetzt gerade zwei Sachen aufgemacht. Das eine ist er twittert einfach mal Kosten Zwanni und twittert dann, okay kostet acht. Ja? Und,
Was er da macht, ist natürlich, also der kann mit seiner,
Elon Musk hat mehr Follower als Twitter. Also ad Twitter hat weniger Follower als Elon Musk,
Der kann natürlich ähm.
Unterhaltsam.
Unglaublich schnell. Der kann unglaublich schnell einfach mal eine Idee prüfen, ja? Einfach mal was raushauen und die Zeitungen sind unmittelbar voll davon,
und er kann ähm er kann sehr schnell einfach prototypische Ideen da rauswerfen und gucken, wie die Leute drauf reagieren. Und es ist es könnte sein, dass der ernsthaft einfach so ähm.
Macht sozusagen.
AB-Testing macht oder dass der, also der kann auch, ich meine es ist schwer zu sagen,
Im Nachhinein kann man natürlich immer irgendwie
kluge Gedanken irgendwo reininterpretieren und das wird bei Elon Musk sehr viel getan, sodass man jetzt zum Beispiel auch sagen könnte, ja der hat einfach das nur mit dem 20 Dollar äh getwittert, damit nachher die acht Dollar günstig erscheinen, ja.
Schachzug. Hier sind meine acht Dollar, ja? Es kann auf jeden Fall sein, ja. Ähm aber was er äh und das ist der ich glaube, was ihm tatsächlich nicht klar ist und wo er wirklich erst jetzt langsam äh sich,
irgendwie versteht. Twitter, ich stimme zu, für diejenigen, die Twitter mögen und nutzen, ist es.
Das ist es fast das alternativlose Social Network, ja? Also Instagram,
habe keine Lust mir irgendwie eine Essstörung oder eine Depression irgendwie anzueignen, indem ich mir die ganze Zeit nur irgendwie solche solche Sachen da angucke, wie alle versuchen, irgend so ein Fake-Leben sich da aufzubauen,
ich mir nicht antun. Äh also habe ich keine Zeit für und so geht nicht, denn äh Facebook weiß ich auch nicht,
ähm und andere, also es ist alles Quatsch, aber es gibt einen ganz großartigen Artikel. Du kennst den ja auch, Tim. Ähm von Nilay Patel, das ist glaube ich Chefredakteur von ähm,
von mit dem Titel welcome to Hallo Elon. Wer nämlich genau sagt so pass auf, was du da gerade gekauft hast.
Ist kein technologisches Problem, das ist nix, was sie irgendwie besser machen kannst, sondern was du da gekauft hast, ist äh ja eine Community, die Menschen, die da sind und du wirst die halten müssen und und wenn das Ding wachsen soll,
Musst du da ähm dafür sorgen, dass das dort angenehm ist und das nämlich Twitter nicht angenehm ist, äh wird hier als der entscheidende Grund,
dargestellt, dass es eben bei weitem nicht so stark wächst wie andere sozialen Netzwerke. Es hat aber natürlich eine Besonderheit, nämlich, wie hier auch sehr schön beschrieben ist, ähm ähm,
Politiker,
und äh sonstige Leute, die einfach süchtig sind nach nach Tweets und Sachen twittern, die sie besser nicht twittern sollten. Eine Reihe an Journalistinnen, das war ja, ich glaube, die einzige kluge Sache, die ähm Doro Beer mal gesagt hat, ne, was hat sie gesagt?
Ist voll mit ähm Politikern, Journalisten und Psychopathen. So so sinngemäß, ja?
Ja.
So so was irgendwie so was in der Art hat sie gesagt. Es ist auch äh wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt, ja?
Ist auch ein Ort, wo man auch Ideen diskutieren kann tatsächlich, ja, in einem bestimmten,
Rahmen, also im Vergleich zu kein Twitter haben, ist Twitter schon wirklich sehr nützlich manchmal. Man kann's natürlich auch vollkommen falsch benutzen und dann ist alles vorbei.
Ja, das hat also tatsächlich genau. Auf Twitter sind nur Politiker-Journals und Psychopathen. Ähm und auf jeden Fall andere ähm Social Networks wachsen mehr und gerade jetzt zu einer äh der jungen Generation
wie es jetzt also eine ist es schwer einem Menschen zu erklären, guck mal hier Twitter geil. Also entweder sagen die sofort,
Geil, ja, Twitter super oder die sagen so, hä? Wie kann ich denn jetzt hier eine Story liken? Ja oder oder so.
Ja ja es ist so alte Leute.
Sind denn hier die Filter, ne.
Leute-Netzwerk, sagen die Kinder jetzt.
Die Kinder, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nee, haben sie nicht. Ich weiß, soll man sagen, ne? Hätte ich auch gesagt.
Okay, aber jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann man dieses Ding, das Ding ist enorm einflussreich und dir der finanzielle Erfolg davon ist bei weitem äh,
Also hinter den hinter dem Einfluss und den Erwartungen zurückbleiben. Jetzt muss man sich überlegen, was kann man daraus machen? Und hier äh Patel schreibt nicht sehr klar, die Leute haben gar keine gar keinen Bock irgendwie neben deinen komischen,
Rassisten rumzuhängen, sondern sie wollen in einem Disney World eben das leben und das heißt du musst,
die Erfahrung dort zu sein sehr, sehr, sehr viel angenehmer gestalten. Und da muss ich echt sagen, ich find's super getroffen,
weil besonders angenehm ist es auf Twitter nicht. Es ist nicht so, als würde man da draufgehen und sagen, oh, ist das aber jetzt hier wieder eine angenehme Erfahrung,
schön auf Twitter bin, ne? Du hast eigentlich ganz also angenehmes, höchstens die diebische Freude dabei, wie sich da am laufenden Band irgendwelche Leute zum zum Brot machen
aber so dass man jetzt sagt so oh schön Twitter, endlich wieder Twitter, die Welt ist in Ordnung. Das ist nicht der Fall, ja. Und,
daran scheitern ja auch alle diese Plattformen äh mit ihrem,
ähm mit ihrem Free Speech Anspruch. Was er also potenziell ähm.
Das Modell zu sagen, okay und das hat ja in einem Interview gesagt so, na ja, wir das kostet jetzt einfach 8 Euro und wenn du diese acht Euro zahlst oder acht Dollar, wenn du das heute acht Dollar, wenn du diese acht Dollar zahlst,
Dann kriegst du diesen Haken, wenn du möchtest oder grundsätzlich und du wirst priorisiert in den Replace. Das heißt, ähm,
Der hat ja irgendwie so sinngemäß gesagt, wenn du dann irgendwie einen Tweet hast und guckst auf die Antworten, dann musst du lange scrollen, bis du da irgendjemanden siehst, der nicht diesen Haken hat,
Ja, mit anderen Worten und das ist also.
So funktioniert das ist seit langer Zeit so, dass man sagt okay du willst normaler, einfacher User sein, ist in Ordnung kriegst du kostenlos, aber wenn du hier irgendwie mitspielen willst oder so, wahrgenommen wirst, nicht Userbase bauen möchtest, dann musst du eben acht,
Dollar zahlen und es ist noch nicht einmal so, dass ich das jetzt ein besonders ähm.
Unsympathisches Geschäftsmodell fände,
Also ich wäre potenziell, wenn ich wenn das Geld jetzt nicht ausgerechnet hat, Elon Musk ginge durchaus bereit zu sagen, okay, ich zahle für für dieses Ding irgendwie acht Euro im Monat. Wenn ich dafür das zum Beispiel auch werbefrei habe,
ne oder für die Möglichkeit dort etwas zu zu sagen, zahle ich irgendwie, was weiß ich, so und so viel, ne? Kann man ja äh also wir haben ja auch mal da musste ich dran denken, hier kennst du noch Tim?
Riesiger äh äh Fan von. Das hat, glaube ich, was hat das gekostet, einen Fünfer im Monat oder so? Hatte allerdings keinerlei Funktionalität.
Da ist egal, also.
Das ist.
Es war ein interessantes Experiment und äh deswegen fand ich's gut,
Ähm das wird nochmal ganz interessant sein, zu sehen
wie sich das jetzt entwickelt, weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass Twitter jetzt sozusagen ausschließlich auf Bezahl-Accounts äh leben kann und auch nicht, dass sie sich davon auch nur nennenswert finanzieren können, es sei denn es gelingt ihnen ihre Betriebskosten nennenswert zu senken.
Ist jetzt auch so eine Idee, der grade mal rausgeworfen hat, das ganze Ding hinter eine Paywall zu werfen.
Also übrigens es gab ja diesen Dienst schon vorher, ne, also um das gleich mal klarzustellen, weil das kommt sonst in den Kommentaren.
Blue gab es vorher.
Twitter Blue und das ist sozusagen, also wir reden nur von diesen äh äh Service-Pack sozusagen. Das gab's in USA, äh Neuseeland,
in Kana, Australien und glaube auch UK und dann war so Features drin im Twitter klein, da kannst du so einen Tweet an du machen, äh und NFT-Profi Pictures.
Oh heulen.
Ja ja ganz toll.
Normale Scheißbild wie jeder andere.
Genau so und und was ja jetzt, ich weiß nicht, hast du's jetzt schon erwähnt, also was ja sozusagen auch mit diesem Paket drin sein soll, ist ja diese Verification, ne, also dieser Haken,
blauer Haken, der sozusagen in irgendeiner Form bestätigen soll, dass dass du halt du bist und ähm das soll jetzt sozusagen eher ausdrückend bezahlst,
Also es ist mehr so ein ich bin hier so ein zahlender Joser.
Also wenn du den nicht haben willst, musst du schnell einen Euro mehr bezahlen, wenn du nicht äh dann als nächstes von den Leuten verarscht werden willst, dass du dafür bezahlst, ne?
Also zahlender Kunde markiert und äh
es jetzt sozusagen darüber hinaus dieses eigentliche, diese eigentliche Idee mit wir identifizieren wir diese Person es äh noch äh geben wird, ist derzeit noch so ein bisschen offen. Es wird gerüchtet, ich weiß es nicht, ich
benutze ja den offiziellen Twitter-Client nicht,
dass jetzt so Präsidenten und so weiter auch noch so einen Text eingeblendet bekommen, wo halt wirklich draufsteht, was für eine Art Position Person es sich hierbei,
handelt sozusagen. Das wäre ja dann etwas, ne? Also alle schreien natürlich jetzt rum, so oh jeder kriegt jetzt einen blauen Haken
Sahaken soll dann irgendwie was anderes bedeuten, wobei das ist natürlich so ein bei den Leuten, also ich glaube nicht, dass alles so wie es jetzt von ihm diskutiert wird, jetzt genauso kommen wird,
und vielleicht sieht die Landschaft in zwei oder drei Wochen schon komplett anders aus,
Das kann schon sein
Das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Fight von ihm werden in irgendeiner Form sowohl die Integrität dieser Community noch aufrechtzuerhalten und sich da nicht äh vom rechten Lager
ähm über ähm rollen zu lassen und ja ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, worauf's hinaus läuft.
Na ja, dann äh also wir sind noch lange nicht durch mit den Geschehnissen. Ich,
immer, dass du immer dass du schon in die Bewertungsphase kommst, aber es gibt noch viel mehr Storys zu erzählen. Zum Beispiel ähm
haben dann Leute angefangen, als er dann mit dem blauen Haken anfing und sagt, der kostet jetzt Geld, dann haben sich Leute, die einen blauen Haken hatten, umbenannt,
Und dann bleibt der blaue Haken,
Haben Sie irgendwelchen Quatsch gemacht? Haben zum Beispiel sich in Elon Musk umbenannt und haben äh ähm,
Dinge getwittert, die jetzt halt als oder im äh relativ klar zu erkennen waren.
Ähm und die insbesondere darauf angesprochen haben, dass es ein Bild von ihm gibt zusammen mit Gilane Maxwell.
Die wie wir wissen jetzt inzwischen glaube ich verurteilte rechte Hand von Jeffrey Appstein,
ähm jemand, mit dem man nicht aufm Bild sein möchte äh und äh jemand, wenn man dem jemals mit dieser Person in der Nähe war oder engere Beziehungen hatte, wo man zurecht äh sich einer ganzen Reihe an Fragen stellen muss.
Ja? Äh Tim, fang dich schon wieder an. Sie heißt.
Alles klar.
Kist.
Ja sie ist britisch, amerikanisch, französisch, ich wusste nicht.
Ähm und dann ähm,
So äh und dann ähm fängt der,
Twittert er. So pass auf, wer jetzt hier irgendwie im Personation macht und das nicht ganz klar als kennzeichnet, wird sofort Permanent Lee Band und,
Band dann ein paar Accounts, unter anderem eine äh US-amerikanische,
Comedian, der Name mir gerade kurz entfallen ist, die irgendwie 2,2 Millionen Follower auf Twitter hatte oder zwei und noch so einen anderen Account, der dann,
Wo du nur noch Screenshots hast, wie gesagt so, okay ich mach's jetzt hier, schreibt sich oben, macht eine Sedda Image, schreibt in die Bioparady.
Ändert sein Bild, äh ändert seinen Namen und äh macht macht, glaube ich, auch was zu,
Kurze Zeit danach ist dieser Account und ein Twitter-Account, ich meine.
Also ein Twitter-Account mit mit zwei Millionen Followern, ne? Das das ist sehr viel Arbeit, denen aufzubauen und der hat einen,
Ja, der hat einen der hat auch einen Wert, ne? Dieses Wert kannst du nicht realisieren. Du kannst jetzt nicht verkaufen, aber das der hat, sagen wir, zumindest einen Streitwert.
Im Sinne von was du da potenziell an Schleichwerbung mit machen kannst, um die Aufmerksamkeit, die du da erlangst, äh an andere zu verkaufen, ne? Was du da an Möglichkeiten hast, deine eigene Marke auszubauen.
Ja und da löscht er die einfach. Zack, bumm, fertig und kloppte halt einfach mal ähm ziemlich,
ziemlich übel einfach mitten rein. Und was wäre natürlich jetzt also man sieht jetzt hier das waren in der Regel die die es da trifft waren Leute die ihnen nachgemacht haben ja? Äh also er hat jetzt,
es mag sein, dass es auch ein ist in der Berichterstattung ist, dass er grundsätzlich gegen Paradie vorgeht, aber es waren primär hat es Leute getroffen, die spezifisch ihnen nachgemacht haben und du kannst dir halt auch so vorstellen, wie da halt ein,
Na ja, wahrscheinlich ziemlich gestresst darf, wie leicht nicht besonders ausgeschlafener Typ äh mit dieser Macht, die ihm da inne wohnt, jetzt auf einmal sehr ähm unsouverän umgeht.
Noch dazu ist er ja gerade hat er in dem Laden Twitter ja wirklich einfach mal für Angst und Schrecken gesorgt. Ja also ähm ich meine, die Leute, die da gearbeitet haben, die haben sich jetzt erstmal paar Monate lang nur von dem beschimpfen lassen dürfen,
wie Scheiße Twitter ist, ja und dann kommt er da rein mit seinem blöden Waschbecken,
So Leute.
Bis da.
In den nächsten in den nächsten vierzehn, also in in 14 Tagen fliegt hier die Hälfte raus. So,
und ähm sagt dann irgendwie mit seinem acht mit seinem acht Dollar Feature sagt er entweder das muss bis dann und dann fertig sein? Wer das nicht schafft äh fliegt raus,
Und hat jetzt ähm tatsächlich dann äh in einer äh in einem sehr kurzen Prozess gesagt ähm,
Hier pass auf, Freitag äh bleibt der Laden zu, bleibt mal alle zu Hause und wartet auf eine E-Mail,
hat den Betreff, der eine Zukunft bei Twitter und da steht drin, ob du am Montag noch kommen musst oder nicht.
Ja und rund 3700 von 7500 Leuten wurden dann halt mal jetzt gefeuert.
Und um was ähm auch da würde ich sagen ähm.
Man kann geteilter Meinung darüber sein,
Ob man für den Betrieb von Twitter siebeneinhalbtausend Leute braucht oder nicht? Das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine ganze Reihe Arbeit, die da sicherlich anfällt, die einem jetzt nicht so unmittelbar präsent ist, zum Beispiel.
Rechtsabteilung.
Werbeanzeigen verkaufen, Rechtsabteilung, äh diese ganze Content-Moderation, ja, den ganzen dass das ganze Ding funktioniert. Ähm
ist tatsächlich auch ein Wunder äh in äh in Datenbanktechnik und Echtzeit und haste nicht gesehen. Also da ist sicherlich auch einiges an Engineering drin,
Und wenn du da reinmarschierst und grade mal zwei Wochen in dem Laden bist, die komplette Führungsriege am ersten Tag rausgeworfen hast und dann einfach mal,
mehr oder weniger wahllos in die Menge Feuers,
ähm dann musst du davon aus, also dann ist es sehr ist es sehr schwer davon auszugehen, dass der ausgerechnet die richtigen 33,7000 Leute,
ähm feuert, ja? Entsprechend stellen sie dann auch raus, ah Scheiße, wir haben ein paar Leute gefolgt, die brauchen wir noch, denen dann gesagt wird, ach scheiße Herr, das tut uns voll leid, dass wir dir diese E-Mail geschickt haben mit dem mit der Entlassung.
Das haben wir gar nicht so gemeint. Du kannst übrigens sehr gerne wiederkommen. Wir sehen uns am Montag. So und gleichzeitig.
In bester Laune natürlich.
Jack Dorsey, der seinen Anteil an Twitter behalten hat.
Also der Founder von Twitter war einer.
Der der der Gründer einer der Gründer von Twitter, übrigens auch ein,
Honk. Also Jack Du hast die wirklich absoluter Honk. Wenn du dir anguckst, wie wie der also was der von sich gibt, ähm,
Und äh ich glaube auch, dass ihm das alles nicht gut gekommen ist, aber anderes Thema. Ja, der ähm übrigens seinen Anteil von Twitter behalten hat und damit Elon Musk eine Milliarde gespart hat, also,
Elon Musk der Jack Dorsey hat jetzt noch eine kleine einen kleinen Anteil an Twitter. Den erhält,
Wobei dir auch dich fragst, warum eigentlich? Du was willst du damit? Kannst du jetzt auch nicht verkaufen? Ist ja jetzt privat oder also wie auch.
Also da ist auch kein Bestimmungsrecht oder so irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung, was sie für einen Deal haben, aber auf jeden Fall hat der hat der dem reichsten Mann der Erde eine Milliarde gespart, was ja auch einfach auch schon mal echt zeigt, dass er ein großes Herz hat, ja? Und ähm.
Tech Bros unter sich.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall so,
Jetzt passiert also Folgendes. Ist offensichtlich mit dem neuen Eigner seines von ihm gegründeten Unternehmens sehr zufrieden,
zwar so zufrieden, dass er seine Anteile dem nicht verkauft, sondern das mit dem
zusammenbehalten will, ja? Wie reagiert jetzt Jack Dorsey auf die Situation, dass Elon Musk gerade 3.700 Leute gefeuert hat, sagt er ja
Mir ist klar, dass viele sauer auf mich sind. Ich bin dafür verantwortlich, dass die Twitter-Angestellten sich jetzt in dieser Lage befinden, denn.
Jetzt kommt die Begründung,
Ich habe das Unternehmen zu schnell wachsen lassen. Dafür entschuldige ich mich. Mit anderen Worten, sorry, dass ihr den Job hattet. Es war mein Fehler, euch anzustellen,
Ähm insofern bin ich verantwortlich für die Situation, dass ihr jetzt gefeuert wurdet. Also das ist äh auch, denke ich, ähm,
erkennbar nicht nicht in Ordnung ja oder also ich denke es ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen, dass du nach zwei Wochen in einem Unternehmen.
Klar erkennen kannst, welche Hälfte der Mitarbeiter du vorher hast,
und ähm ich glaube aber grundsätzlich schon, dass äh bei so einem Unternehmen sich äh über die Jahre ganz schön viel ansetzt und dass das grundsätzlich,
nicht das Todesurteil von Twitter sein wird, dass man da einfach mal die Hälfte der Leute feuert und guckt, was als Nächstes passiert.
Ja, also die Liste wird es sicherlich schon länger gegeben haben. Die hat jetzt nicht Elon Musk sich irgendwie auf dem Weg von der Lobby.
Wer hat ihr dem nicht wer hat sie ihm denn geschrieben?
Ja weiß nicht. Vielleicht.
Es kann sein.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist ja da auch so eine kleine Welt, dieses ganze Silikon Valley, also na ja.
Jedenfalls so äh ich glaube, jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich fast alle
äh aufregenden Geschichten so grob zusammengefasst, wahrscheinlich auch ein paar vergessen. Dann hat er zwischendurch noch äh,
äh gesagt, man soll jetzt die Republikaner wählen, der hat jetzt auch keiner sich gewundert, dass er das tut. Aber es macht natürlich auch ähm ja keinen.
Keinen schmalen Fuß, wenn sich grade alle darum sorgen, dass dieser ähm,
dass dieser Mensch jetzt gerade hier eben eine der einflussreichsten Kommunikationsplattformen des Planeten gekauft hat,
Gleichzeitig glaube ich, dass der also man merkt da gerade echt so ein bisschen so ein ich weiß nicht, ob der,
Wie viel davon er spielt, aber einen klaren Plan,
scheint er nicht zu haben, was ich ihm aber positiv anrechnen würde, ist, dass er in der Lage ist.
Dass er vermutlich in der Lage sein wird,
den richtigen Plan zu finden, weil er eben auch mal wirklich etwas an dem Ding ändert. Insofern, es kann es tatsächlich vorsichtig,
sich rückblickend als die ja die Rettung der Plattform erwiesen haben, dass da einfach mal einer reingeht, der Entscheidungen trifft,
mit massiven Auswirkungen, die innerhalb von 14 Tagen umgesetzt werden und umgesetzt werden können,
Das kann potenziell Twitter äh relativ schnell komplett ruinieren,
Es kann aber auch dazu führen, dass diese Plattform vielleicht tatsächlich ähm einen Weg findet zu einem.
Noch einflussreicheren weltweiten Debattenmedium zu werden,
Ausgeschlossen ist es nicht. Bisher finde ich's erst mal unterhaltsam, wie er äh echt einfach.
Erkennbar auch ein bisschen überfordert ist und halt dieser Schlingerkurs mit den Entlassungen und so, das zeigt schon, dass da dass da ein bisschen äh Unsicherheit auch drin ist.
Vor allem das hat das Ding sechs Monate lang niedergeschrien hat, ähm aber am Ende werden ihn eh alle als ein Genie bezeichnen.
Während wirklich wirklich wirklich massiv Menschen Twitter verlassen,
Sich ja das, doch, doch, das ist schon ganz klar, um sich äh Masterdown-Accounts zu holen.
Denn was wir überhaupt nicht äh besprochen haben ist, dass es ja eine ein grundsätzlich.
Bemerkenswertes und auch kritikwürdiges Phänomen ist, wenn ein Mann so eine Macht hat, ne. Dieses mit dem wir werfen Leute raus, die die mich im Personaten.
Und das ist halt schon ich meine, das war bei ein Problem oder ist es immer noch, ne, aber was.
Also ich kann auch verstehen, dass die Leute jetzt mit Unbehagen.
Du hast das natürlich deine Frage die richtige, ob die jetzt wirklich also ob die ein Twitter-Account geschlossen haben,
dahingestellt, aber die machen sich jetzt immerhin schon mal mit den alternativen vertraut.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass das Abwanderungsproblem ist derzeit ähm bestenfalls in in so Rändern von Leuten, die jetzt eh nicht so in Twitter äh investiert sind und,
Dann aber jetzt auch nicht bereit wären, äh Twitter sofort zu verlassen. Also der dieser Empörungszustand ist noch lange nicht erreicht, dass man jetzt sagt,
Heute ist ja Twitter noch so,
hat sicher an meinem Twitter bisher nichts verändert. Es gibt nur ominöse Ankündigungen, komische Tweets, die äh ich zum Beispiel persönlich, weil ich Elon Musk aus Prinzip nicht folge, auch gar nicht,
mitkriege und ich lese auch nicht den ganzen Tag Elon Musk Fan,
Tweets oder Newsartikel oder so, mich interessieren andere Sachen und wenn wenn da mal wirklich was Wichtiges sagt, dann kriege ich das sowieso mit.
Wird das schon irgendwie über die zweite oder dritte Reihe oder du erzählst mir das.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass wir viel mitbekommen hast. Also ich musste dir jetzt schon eine ganze Menge erzählen von den von den wichtigsten Tweets der letzten vierundzwanzig.
Das das denkst du nur, du hast ja jetzt nicht gefragt, was was ich davon schon wusste oder oder oder nicht.
Ein, zwei Details wusste ich nicht, aber fand ich jetzt auch nicht so ähm überraschend, sagen wir's mal so. Ähm überraschender finde ich übrigens, dass du mittlerweile mehr Follower hast als ich. Habe ich denn das gemacht?
Bestehtes Arbeiten an der eigenen Marke und vor allem nicht diesen blauen.
Ran, ran wanzen.
Diesen blauen Haken, der.
Ja, den habe ich, ne, der zählt, der zählt dann halt nochmal doppelt, ne. Von daher ja willst du wissen, wo ich den her habe?
Ja, du wolltest genau, du wolltest die Geschichte erzählen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
habe den irgendwann einfach bekommen.
Und ich kann mir das nur so erklären. Es gab halt diese frühe deutsche Twitteria so, ich sage mal so, die Leute, die so in den ersten ein, zwei Jahren äh in Deutschland zu Twitter dazugekommen sind, nachdem's das gab,
In dem Zeitraum falle ich halt auch und,
Bist du auch schon von Anfang an dabei, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gab's ja hier so ein ich sage mal.
Eine überschaubare deutsche Netzgemeinde. Ja. Und dann hat Twitter ein deutsches Büro aufgemacht in Berlin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer da gearbeitet hat. Aber die werden sich halt Leute gesucht haben, die in Deutschland in irgendeiner Form Netz kennen.
So und mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht sagen, weil ich hatte den einfach irgendwann,
den Haken. Ich habe da nicht ich habe da nicht danach gefragt, weil es gab,
gar keinen Prozess danach zu fragen. Also das gab keinen formalen Weg.
Ja ja, das das gab's nicht.
Das zu tun. Ich hatte den einfach irgendwann und ich kann nur vermuten, dass irgendjemand bei Twitter in Deutschland gesessen hat, der sehr wohl wusste, wer hinter dem bekannten ist.
Und dass der von Tim Brüttler auch bespielt wird und einfach gesagt hat, da machen wir jetzt auch einen scheiß Haken dran. Keine Ahnung wie also wenn wenn du da draußen bist und du bist schuld,
Ja äh bitte melde dich. Also ich würde das mal nicht, aber.
War der denn auf einmal einfach da oder äh.
Ich mich erinnern kann, weil er einfach irgendwann einfach mal da. Ich habe keine Mail dazu bekommen, gar nix.
Ja, jetzt kostet der 8 Euro. Ja ja, das war ja klar pro Monat.
Jetzt ist ja nichts mehr wert. Wenn das so kommt,
ich ihn immer noch bezweifle, weil dieses Verification-Problem ist natürlich schon das finde ich ist also das finde ich so ein bisschen merkwürdig, wie er damit umgeht, weil,
Das ist natürlich albern, weil dieses Netzwerk wenn es irgendetwas braucht, dann ist es ja mehr Vertrauen in die Person, die dort was,
äußern, ja? Auch ich bin schon irgendwelchen Scammern mal auf den Leim äh gegangen und habe
bewahre auch irgendwelche äh rechten Vollidioten mal retweetet, weil sie mal ausnahmsweise mal irgendwas Interessantes äh getwittert haben und ich dann erst danach drauf hingewiesen wurde, wer denn das ist.
Ich habe schon ein gewisses Bedürfnis nach hm Authentizität und das spiegelt sich ja auch sagen wir mal in meinem Nickname,
Wieder, ja. Ich bin auf allen Netzwerken immer Tim Prettlove, weil einerseits ist das relativ unique handle, andererseits ähm war,
daran gelegen, nicht irgendwie in so ein anonymen Kostüm äh rüberzukommen, sondern ich wollte schon auch immer als ich und als meine Person da sein. Entsprechend halte ich mich dann aber auch eigentlich mit meinen öffentlichen Kommentaren zur Gesamtlage auch ein bisschen zurück, nicht immer, aber meistens.
Und das mag ähm vielleicht bei dieser Entscheidung dann auch,
Rolle gespielt haben, ne.
Genutzt hat's mir nicht viel. Also ich äh kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass dieser blaue Haken in irgendeiner also zumindest habe ich das nicht so wahrgenommen, ja? Das das es irgendwelche Türen öffnet oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ähm also wenn wenn es Türen gab, die sich da damit hätten öffnen können, dann bin ich ihnen nicht nahe gekommen. Also.
Denke, also.
Es wird es wird absolut, also wie du schon sagst, es wird der Haken wird wertlos, wenn man ihn kaufen kann.
Es gab hier auch irgendwelche ähm irgendwelche,
Tweets in denen behauptet wurde, dass ähm,
dieser Haken verkauft wurde, dass also Twitter, Mitarbeitende.
So hintenrum.
Hinten rum gesagt haben, na ja pass auf, wir lehnen das jetzt mal ab, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, für ein paar tausend Euro äh meine Meinung noch mal zu revidieren.
Das halte ich auch für durchaus denkbar, dass das passiert ist.
Absolut. Das ist so ein Netzbling.
Aber ähm genau, also äh so etwas.
Goldkettchen, das ist das Goldkettchen des Internets dieser blaue Haken.
Ja irgendwie so was, ne?
Ja, das bringt gar nix. Äh viele haben das so, sieht auch überall gleich aus,
nix, aber irgendwie manche Leute der Meinung, sie müssen's trotzdem tragen.
Aber es ist natürlich in so einer in so einer Diskussion äh in so einem online, in so einer Online-Agora ähm.
Schon ich glaube, es ist wichtig, das zu haben,
Ja? Oder auch zum Beispiel um sich gegen ähm ja gegen Impersination, zu Schutz zu schützen, ne? Dass man weiß, ah, hier,
Elon Musk ist ein very fight ähm äh Account, der hat einen äh blauen Haken und wenn da irgendeiner ohne blauen Haken kommt, dann ist es im Zweifelsfall nicht derjenige, äh für den er sich ausgibt. So ist ja schon.
Also es wäre viel sinnvoller, dass man irgendwie so eine Proof Bio hat oder so, dass man einfach mal einen Absatz äh schreiben kann und irgendwie das ist dann halt belegt, dass die Informationen, die da drin stehen, auch äh stimmen.
Und ähm das würde schon mal eine Menge ausmachen und dann hätte ich auch sagen wir mal.
Gegen irgendwelche ja Priorisierung ist vielleicht nicht das Richtige Wort, aber ich hätte mir schon immer,
wünscht, dass ich, sagen wir mal, in gewisser Hinsicht auch meinen,
bestimmte Diskussionen bisschen einschränken kann, also gar nicht so sehr jetzt was auf mich betrifft oder so, also auf an meinen Accounts, sondern,
Diskussionsretze irgendwie, die man,
verfolgt. Was würdest du dir denn wünschen, eigentlich von Twitter, wenn du jetzt so drei Wünsche frei hättest, äh was Elon Musk bei Twitter mal einführen darf, was was was wäre denn so das Wichtigste für dich?
Also ich bin der ganzen Sache gegenüber ja, also ich habe mich jetzt entschieden das erstmal ähm.
Interessiert von der Seitenlinie zu betrachten und mich darüber ähm äh lustig zu machen, ja? Also.
Unabhängig von Elon Musk, also was würdest du dir sozusagen an Verbesserungen wünschen als Benutzer dieses Netzwerks, von dem wir ja nun festgestellt haben, dass es einen gewissen Wert für uns darstellt.
Tatsächlich habe ich mir da keine Gedanken drüber gemacht. Genauso wenig wie Elon Musk das bisher wahrscheinlich äh gemacht hat,
ich ich also ich würde erstmal schon sagen, dass ich in dem ähm in dem,
Modus bin, das ist jetzt erstmal wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt,
ist, dass ein ähm.
Einen Mann so viel Reichtum äh.
Kommen äh anhäufen kann, dass er so einen Laden einfach mal zu übernimmt und sich den aneignet und im Prinzip da zum Alleinherrscher wird und dass er dass er diese Macht auch ausnutzt hat er eben mit dieser,
sehr äh unsouverän und kleinlichen Reaktionen, dass ein paar Leute ihn verarschen ähm schon mal gezeigt, ja ähm.
Genau. Es ist aber auch äh so eine Sache ob das jetzt unbedingt so viel schlimmer ist, als dass so ein Unternehmen,
öffentlich gehandelt ist, ja? Also offensichtlich hat es sich da hat es da bessere Selbstblockaden gehabt, um um sich zu verändern
ähm die jetzt eben nicht mehr so in dieser Form da sind, weil er die weil er die Hälfte der Leute gefeuert hat und jetzt jeder einfach macht, was er sagt.
Es gibt da durchaus natürlich hier von
ähm dem UN-Sonderbeauftragten für Meinungsfreiheit von dem Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland von der ganzen Menge Menschen, die halt wissen, wie viel Einflusswitter hat durchaus besorgte Stimmen.
Ja und die sind auch denke ich nicht zu ähm zu unterschätzen.
So zwei Vektoren aufmachen, ne? So was ist so,
kommen, weil ich glaube irgendwo dazwischen wird's liegen ähm
Also was mich persönlich am meisten beunruhigt, sind vor allem jetzt die grade stattfindenden Wahlen in den USA, je nachdem, wie das äh ausgeht und inwiefern halt einfach diese ganze politische Debatte in USA umschlägt oder ob sich sozusagen auch,
damit dann die ähm Machtverhältnisse
nochmal wieder verschlechtern in den USA, sodass halt irgendwie die äh Republikaner wieder in der Lage sind, äh Dinge zu blockieren, wie zum Beispiel die Unterstützung
USA für die Ukraine und äh viele andere Sachen auch. Äh das haben wir ja alle schon gesehen, wohin die Reise gehen würde, wenn wenn die da ähm das.
Des Handels mehr wieder in die eigene Hand nehmen können.
Das äh macht mir jetzt gerade am meisten Angst und ich hoffe, dass wir dann nächste Woche so ein bisschen Entwarnung geben können, aber weiß ich nicht. Werden wir sehen.
Ich äh hatte jetzt ohnehin schon so ein bisschen Bedenken, was gerade so sein Verhältnis auch zum äh betrifft, so ne? Weil das ist äh fast noch eine kritischere Infrastruktur. Ich glaube, Twitter, das ist äh
neben Kriegsschauplatz aber Starling ist ein echter Kriegsschauplatz und ähm,
derzeit gibt's viele äh Terminals, die da ausgeschaltet sind, weil sie nicht
bezahlt sind und sowieso ein bisschen unklar und es geht um so 20 Millionen Dollar, was irgendwie Gesamtkosten dieses Krieges irgendwie auch alles ein bisschen albern ist. Also ist grade alles total unklar, was da abgeht und mir ist einfach seine politische Positionierung
in diesem ganzen Spiel so ein bisschen unklar und ich habe das Gefühl der ist eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht so ein richtig politischer Typ,
Aber es ist halt einfach so, dass diese Leute, die so superreich sind, die fühlen sich ja auch einfach enthaltend, sich überall irgendwie rein zu,
so dass die dann einfach zu allem ihren Senf dazu abgeben können und weil sie auch noch so viele Leute gibt, die reiche Leute einfach per se in irgendeiner Form für wichtig halten äh ja also deren.
Sogenannte Prominenz dann auch äh daraus ableiten, dass jetzt deren Meinungen, Aussagen und Handeln äh richtungsweisen sein müsse,
Ähm deswegen und und und die Leute sind sich dessen nicht ausreichend bewusst, ne. Also was was wir, glaube ich, auch schon mal so ein bisschen diskutiert haben, was hier jetzt gar nicht, ne? Also allein schon so diese Mikroöffentlichkeit
die wir hier jetzt haben, so mit unserem kleinen Podcast, irgendwie so mit 50.000 Hörer, 50.000 Follower und so weiter. Das ist so
Das ist jetzt wenn diese Leute alle morgens bei dir vor der Tür stehen und hallo sagen irgendwie, dann ist das irgendwie so, aber es ist irgendwie kein Vergleich zu so einer globalen Bereitschaft, aber trotzdem hast du in so einem kleinen
Kreis natürlich auch Verantwortung. So wir haben auch eine Verantwortung hier,
Wir uns öffentlich äußern und der versuchen wir in irgendeiner Form gerecht zu werden, indem wir,
mindestens unsere Worte abwägen und immer,
Auch Diskussionen darüber haben, ne. Was muss gesagt werden, was.
Ist vielleicht schwierig all diese ganzen Sachen. Wie sagt man etwas wo hält man besser einfach erstmal die Schnauze, weil die Dinge unklar sind,
wo es man vielleicht auch selber gerade viel zu wütend auf irgendetwas, dass man das Thema vielleicht auch erstmal weglässt und sich runterkocht eine Woche später äh drüber reden. All solche,
Aspekte und das scheint mir bei manchen Leuten, die so in dieser Superöffentlichkeit stehen, vollkommen abhanden
gekommen zu sein und Elon Musk da irgendwie ganz weit vorne. Also das ist so sein das Hauptproblem, was ich gerade sehe ist, dass er einfach mehr oder weniger aus
unbedachtsamkeit oder eben vielleicht auch Neugewonnener politischer Radikalisierung, weil er ist ja auch irgendwie so ein alter Buddy von diesem Betathiel und so, also sein Umgang ist auch irgendwie nicht,
okay so ja und dazu hast du auch noch viele,
und du bist halt auch noch so ein mega Sprachrohr und das kann halt einfach mega,
schiefgehen. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich jetzt so sage, okay, jetzt kann's maximal gut werden. Du hast das ja auch schon angesprochen.
Okay, er hat mit Tesla, mit SpaceX und PayPal, wobei ich nicht genau weiß, was er eigentlich sein konkreter Einfluss war, aber.
Geld äh Geld in den Laden investiert, ne? Also das ist ja bei allen anderen Läden von ihm auch so.
Ja, aber er hat ja auch eine gewisse Entscheidungshoheit bei äh Tesla und eine gewisse Entscheidungshoheit bei SpaceX sicherlich nicht,
Dass er über alles entscheidet so, aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass er,
da nichts bewirken würde und seine Art und Weise diese Läden zu führen haben ja dann auch.
Zu Ergebnissen geführt, so die mal eben so, dass,
die die Diätautomarke ist, die jetzt wirklich den den die Verkehrswende weltweit eingeleitet hat. Ich denke, das kann man einfach mal so festhalten und mal so ganz nebenbei die erfolgreichste und technologisch am fortgeschrittenste
Space Lounge Firma gegründet innerhalb von zehn Jahren,
Von irgendwie wir wissen nicht, ob unsere Rakete fliegt zu äh niemand baut auch nur im Ansatz, äh so was erfolgreiches wie wir,
das ist schon echt super beeindruckend und Starlink ist noch ein bisschen die Story, weil es glaube ich viele Leute noch nicht auf dem Zettel haben, weil das eben nichts ist, was man einfach mal so mitbenutzt, ne, aber alle Leute, die irgendwie so eine Schüssel haben,
Ich gehöre dazu und sagt ja, man nimmt das Ding in Betrieb und dann ist schon erstmal der Mund offen, so ein bisschen. Und das.
Kann halt also auch bedeuten
dass er sich da rein wurschtet ja, dass er in so einem Lernprozess, in so einem hyperschnellen Lernprozess, weil es ja ein flinker äh Denker ganz offensichtlich nach zwei, drei Monaten feststellt so, ah.
Wir müssen's ganz anders machen, ja? Fakt, was ich gestern getwittert habe, ist alles.
Alles Unsinn.
Ist alles egal. Äh wir machen das jetzt irgendwie, wir machen hier 1achtzig Grad und gehen in die andere Richtung, weil jetzt ähm haben wir genug Leute äh eingeflüstert, was was meine geniale Idee von morgen ist.
Das machen wir dann einfach so. Das kann halt auch passieren. Und es kann halt auch sein, dass er irgendwie seine Liebe zur offenen, demokratischen Gesellschaft entdeckt, weil dann funktioniert das auch mit den Werbekunden viel besser, wenn man nicht scheiße ist.
So und das wäre so die der positive Winkel. Ich halte beides irgendwie für fast,
Gleich wahrscheinlich oder,
Ja. Also mag da vielleicht so eine Inbalance geben, aber die könnte ich jetzt in Zahlen nicht ausdrücken. Und das ist so ein bisschen, was uns da bevorsteht. Es wird jetzt auf jeden Fall ein krasses Experiment und es ist halt auch leider ein Trend,
den wir halt fortgeschrieben sehen jetzt durch diese ganzen Techgrößen, was ja vorhin schon ähm,
Ja äh Vogel australische Zeitungs äh Vogel.
Mörder erwähnt, genau. Ja der ja nun.
Im Prinzip ja sicher auch diese Medien auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise einverleiht hat. Bei ihm waren's halt Zeitungen und später dann,
Fernsehsender und die haben auch seine Agenda durchgebracht und seine Agenda ist halt ja Leute, ihr schreibt das.
Werden muss, damit die Leute das wählen und das glauben und das unterstützen, was was reiche Leute brauchen.
Ne? Das ist einfach das Ding und das ist so das Problem von reichen Leuten, dass sie einfach meistens dann doch irgendwie ihre eigenen Interessen
vertreten und so viel Geld haben andere Leute dafür zu bezahlen, dass sie diese
Interessen auch vertreten, das ist dann halt einfach der Weg der Dinge ist und den gibt's halt sowas wie die britische Boulevard-Presse und Fox News und all diesen ganzen Quatsch. Also wenn wir in Deutschland Gott sei Dank auch ein bisschen weit weg
Da hast du so Vögel wie diesen Amazon äh Chef, ja Jeff Bezos,
der irgendwie auch irgendwie ein ist, aber beileibe nicht so viel twittert, also ich glaube gar nicht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, auf der Twitte.
Nee, ich glaube, der der der twittert nicht. Gut, der kauft sich dann halt irgendwie das äh die Washington Post. So,
Die hat da jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren ist da irgendwie bekannt geworden, dass die Welt umgefallen ist dadurch.
Nö, ich glaube auch nicht, dass also ich glaube nicht, dass die bei was die äh im entferntesten so einflussreich ist äh oder so teuer. Ich glaube, die hat ja für 50 Millionen gekauft oder so was.
Ja ja klar, aber auch das ist sozusagen so eine äh weißt du, wenn wenn du halt.
Deine Tageseinnahmen irgendwie so im im achtstelligen Bereich hast, äh dann denkst du ja über Investitionen und Ausgeachten ganz anders nach. Und dann äh ich rede nicht aus Erfahrung. Und dann.
Kaufst du dir halt Spielzeug. So, kaufst dir halt Sachen, die dich glücklich machen und lange Zeit waren, die Reichen halt mit Schlössern und Yachten und äh Häusern und,
anderen Dingen Dienstleistungen zufrieden und dicken Autos und jetzt ist es halt auch mehr so dieses Einflussnehmen,
Nicht nur so die totalen Vögel wie dieser Mörder, sondern es ist jetzt irgendwie auch so, ja man will jetzt im Medienzirkus und diesem ganzen Aufmerksamkeitsbusiness auch irgendwie eine eine Rolle spielen und das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau,
wo ich auf uns zurollen wird. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, wir werden's bald erfahren.
Ja, es ich denke, da kann jetzt eine ganz also da das kann,
Mann, also Dinge werden nicht werden am Ende in der Regel nicht ganz so schlimm, äh wie man äh sie sich vorstellt. Das wird schon irgendwie halbwegs gut gehen ähm bisher finde ich's erstmal sehr unterhaltsam. Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Potenzial.
Twitter zu verbessern. Ja ich bin mal gespannt, ob er dieses Potenzial äh,
findet und ob er die gleichen Ideen von Verbesserungen hat, aber ähm wenn man vielleicht mal seine,
Er hat ja gesagt, dass er das äh dass er Twitter gekauft hat, weil er die Menschheit so liebt. Die sich die sich dort abbildet, ja?
Aber ich liebe doch alle.
Also im Moment würde ich trotzdem sagen, dass er der hat jetzt irgendwie grade vor kurzem noch getwittert. Ja twitter hat mehr Zugriffe als je zuvor. Ja klar, weil.
Weil Twitter halt ein verhältnismäßig kleines soziales Netzwerk ist, was allen Journalistinnen und Journalisten als Primärquelle dient und wenn er da irgendwie twittert, dann schreiben sie doch immer.
Und jetzt denken natürlich alle, äh also so viele Menschen wie Twitter nicht nutzen,
die halt Nachrichten lesen und denken so, Scheiße, den ganzen Tag ist davon Twitter die Rede.
Da muss es jetzt jetzt muss ich da auch mal draufklicken, was der äh Elon Muske da macht.
Na ja, also schauen wir's uns mal an. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein absolut kurioses Ding. Ich gebe zu, ich hätte echt nicht damit gerechnet, ich find's supergeil oder super unterhaltsam, wie er jetzt halt,
Im Prinzip Twitter schon wirklich echt kaputt macht,
Und gleichzeitig aber auch Twitterin kaputt macht. So das finde ich eine richtig schöne Symbiose.
Mach kaputt, was dich kaputt macht. Ähm ich habe übrigens habe ich gerade nochmal nachgeschlagen ähm mit dem Max habe ich mal einen,
Podcast gemacht über Twitter. Im dritten Jahr wird das äh Existenz nämlich im Februar zweitausendneun.
Twitter noch ausdrucken, ne.
Ja da waren die Tweets auch nicht so lang, waren's nur 140 Zeichen. Ähm.
Das war so eine Serie von von Dingen, wo wir irgendwie über äh Zukunftstechnologien äh im Internet gesprochen haben.
Was sozusagen alles in irgendeiner Form vielleicht nur eine Bedeutung haben wird oder auch nicht,
Und die erste Folge war dann auch gleich über Twitter.
Ich habe selber schon lange nicht mehr reingehört. Könnt ihr ja mal machen. Ist nur eine Stunde. Ist vielleicht ganz unterhaltsam. Äh könnt ihr in den Kommentaren dann äh schreiben, was ich irgendwie richtig gefunden habe oder nicht.
Okay, dann kommen wir ja äh zum nächsten Thema.
Ja äh wir haben ja eigentlich jetzt nur noch kurze Themen, aber äh ein Thema würde ich hier tatsächlich gerne mal äh noch kurz benennen und zwar,
haben wir natürlich hier auch vor einigen Monaten darüber gesprochen.
Dass ein äh Gericht, ich glaube in München, war das geurteilt, hat dass die Einwendung von Google Frontz ähm,
im Prinzip,
Dass da der rechtfertigende Notstand fehlt. Ja äh um das mal äh juristisch falsch auszudrücken, das berechtigte Interesse, Google Fonds zu nutzen
ist nicht da, weil es sich um eine Trivialdienstleistung handelt, diese Schriften bereitzustellen, die man genauso gut auf dem eigenen Server hosten kann,
und deswegen hat dieses äh Gericht geurteilt, dass das eben, ja, das hier,
nicht du das kein berechtigtes Interesse vorliegt, die die IP-Adresse,
Der Besucherin deiner Seite an an Google zu verraten, wo sie dann äh Raubmord getrackt wird, ja.
Und ähm.
Damals warnte sehr früh äh ich glaube hier ähm also mehrere Leute aus dem CCC-Kontext auf jeden Fall auch. Das sich daraus jetzt eine Abmahnwelle ergeben.
Und da gibt es tatsächlich Menschen, die sich auch dafür nicht zu schade sind, die jetzt Abmahnungen versenden,
Die machen Folgendes, äh ich habe so eine, also eine Abmahnung kann man sehen, kann man sich auch anschauen. Ich habe so auch äh einem mir mal angeschaut, weil ein Bekannter die bekommen hat
Die schicken dir dann also, ja, wir waren auf ihrer Webseite und da wurde jetzt hier ist der IP-Adresse an den Google gegangen,
Deswegen wollen wir jetzt 170 Euro Schadensersatz haben.
Und diese ähm Abmahnung, dass eigentlich der Hauptgrund, äh warum ich diese Teil hier überhaupt erwähne,
Die werden versendet von Kilian Lehnhardt als Anwalt und Martin Ismael, Ismael aus Hannover, der sich als Vertreter der Interessengemeinschaft Datenschutz äh hier engagiert,
um dem Datenschutz zu helfen, indem äh sie eben von irgendwelchen Menschen, die irgendeine Webseite haben, 170 Euro erpressen wollen und wenn man sich dazu ein bisschen äh über Google informiert,
findet man ähm eine Reihe von ähm Anwälten, die also ganz klar sagen, dass dieses Verhalten rechtsmissbräuchlich ist.
Dass welches äh Verhalten.
Versenden von Massenabmahnungen, weil davon auszugehen ist, dass Martin Ismael aus Hannover, wenn er eine Webseite zum Beispiel in Berlin besucht, überhaupt nicht das Interesse hegt,
sagen wir,
diese äh dieses Haarstudio, diesen Friseursalon überhaupt zu besuchen, sondern einfach nur mit dem mit dem Ziel besucht,
äh dort festzustellen, ob's da Googlephones gibt, damit der 170 Euro abpressen kann zusammen mit Kilian Lehnhardt. Und aus diesem Grunde sollte man äh diesen Menschen unter keinen Umständen Geld geben.
Sind aber nicht die einzigen, die das tun, sondern es gibt auch die R A AG Kanzlei Dickigorus Keiris.
Ähm äh aus Meerbusch, das ist eine Stadt in der Nähe von Düsseldorf, die für ähm Abmahnungen versendet,
die beginnen mit, bitte nehmen sie Kenntnis davon, dass sich das anwaltliche Interesse von Herrn Wangju rechtsfreundlich wahrnehme?
Wahrscheinlich auch so ein äh schöner.
Ein wichtiger Begriff.
Wichtiger Begriff. Ähm aber ich denke, es ist es.
Weil das ja auch Anwälte sind, ne und mit Anwälten muss man ja vorsichtig sein ähm,
Würde ich jetzt gar nicht weiter was dazu sagen, wie ich jetzt deren Gebaren ähm einordne,
aber ich äh würde sagen, dass äh dass äh hier relativ erkenntlich ist, dass äh,
wir dafür äh diese Gesetze nicht haben,
diese Menschen äh zur Bereicherung ansetzen und irgendwelche Menschen abmahnen und mit mit bösen Druckbriefen versuchen äh von denen Geld abzupressen.
Ja, ein bisschen Trauerspiel, dass wir da jetzt immer noch keine gesetzlichen Maßnahmen ergriffen haben. So war's einfach im Keim zu ersticken.
Ja, das ist wirklich äh dramatisch, dass man so was, dass dass man solche rechtsmissbräuchlichen Geschäftsmodelle äh weiterhin ermöglicht. Aber es bleibt natürlich zu hoffen,
dass die Leute sich zu ausreichend Ruhm verhelfen
ähm dass ihnen sage ich mal ähm andere Wege das Gelderwerbs als Rechtsanwälte,
auch zunehmend erschwert werden ja sehr dramatisch aber,
Gleichzeitig muss man natürlich auch sagen,
Man sollte nicht nur das jetzt mal zum Anlass nehmen äh Google Fons aus seiner Webseite zu entfernen. Es ist relativ ähm einfach inzwischen
lokal zu hosten. Ähm.
Damals, als das anfing, war das noch nicht so einfach. Äh der Hauptgrund, dass es Googlephones gab, war eben, dass du für jeden Browser andere Formate brauchtest äh und die halt dir die Arbeit abgenommen haben und dir auch eine ganze Reihe
Anschriften ja freilizensiert haben, die es vielleicht äh die sie im Prinzip freigekauft haben, um das Internet schöner zu machen.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich, ich meine vielleicht in in so düsteren Zeiten äh kann ich auf jeden Fall Genuss daraus schöpfen, dass ich nicht auf diese Weise mein Geld verdiene.
Frag den Staat äh hat äh zusammen mit Böhmermann, mit der äh,
ZDF Royal Show oder wie das heißt ähm die sogenannten NSU-Akten veröffentlicht und da muss man natürlich sagen, die NSU-Akten ähm,
Da steht über eine ganze Menge was drin, außer über den NSU,
denn der große Skandal am NSU ist ja, dass diese Nazimörderbande über ich glaube ein Jahrzehnt,
in Deutschland getötet hat.
Und die Mordopfer dann von den Strafverfolgungsbehörden verunglimpft wurden als irgendwie heimliche Angehörige der organisierten Kriminalität, weil man sich sonst ja nicht,
ähm erklären könnte, äh warum denn so ein Kriecher,
oder so ein Türke am äh am am helllichten Tag einfach erschossen wird. Ja und ähm die Akten sollten unter Verschluss bleiben. Wir wissen auch, dass Teile davon, als dann der NSU aufflog, wurde ja sehr,
hektisch geschreddert und der äh nicht geschredderte Teil ähm da wurden also jetzt diese Daten veröffentlicht. Ähm
Und da kann man natürlich auch sehr schön drauf achten, wer in einer solchen Situation dann daran Kritik übt, ja, zum Beispiel unser äh Bundeskanzler,
Olaf Scholz, äh der ja auch äh wirklich im also.
Jetzt auch gar nicht mehr so viel zu ein zu dem Typen.
Ne?
Bräuchte mal so einen Coach oder so.
Ja oder vielleicht einen anderen Job?
Bei der Warburgbank oder wie die heißen.
Ja also Vizekanzler hatte er eigentlich ganz gut hingekriegt.
Kannst du leider gut hingekriegt, ja. Österreich hat sich ähm,
gegen äh die,
Chatkontrolle ausgesprochen, wird also auf den EU-Verhandlungen auf der Seite der Kritiker stehen. Ähm das gibt also einen Parlamentsausschuss, der sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat, der hat eine Stellungnahme beschlossen,
diese Stellungnahme richtet sich gegen die allgemeinen Überwachungspflichten,
Und das hat äh durchaus eine relevante Wirkung, weil Österreichs sich jetzt eben so verhalten muss und ähm.
Man darf hoffen, dass unsere Freundinnen und Freunde von der Grünen Partei und unsere Freundinnen und Freunde von der von den Freien Demokraten,
Jetzt langsam erwachen,
Zumindest ähm führt auch die grüne äh Bundestagsfraktion jetzt ein Informationsgespräch äh gegen
Chatkontrolle durch, ein Fachgespräch im Deutschen Bundestag. Das heißt, man äh kann jetzt hier hoffen, dass sie sich mal langsam Mühe geben
nennt sie Phaser und die Besetzer ihres Hauses da in ihre Schranken zu weisen. Also Österreich als äh Vorbild zu nehmen,
In diesem in diesem Themenbereich äh gut.
Genau, ich wollte auch grad sagen, so Österreich da da freuen sich jetzt alle Österreicher sehr.
Das das immer was das endlich mal.
Einfach mal so als Vorbild äh.
Ja ich bin mir sicher, dass Thomas da irgendwo äh nicht weit weit von entfernt war, als das passiert ist. Äh,
Ihnen mal äh bei Gelegenheit fragen.
Wir hatten ihn auch schon lange nicht mehr zu Gast, fällt mir aber auf.
Ja der äh ja kann ja auch barkommen. Muss ja nicht immer von uns ausgehen. Die.
Bist du selber Schuld, hast du ja nicht gefragt.
Er wird sicherlich bald wieder hier zu Gast sein.
Das ticke ich auch.
Und äh dann natürlich was weiterhin so ein bisschen vor sich hin plätschert, ist die Laufzeitverlängerung der ähm,
Zertifikate in den Konnektoren, über die wir ja mit Flipke gesprochen haben, ähm.
Und die medical ähm ist jetzt ja eigentlich relativ klar, dass die äh nicht äh gemäß der Fakten argumentiert, wenn sie behauptet äh man äh müsste,
Äh die Hardware tauschen. Die CT hat ja auch schon gezeigt, man kann auch die SG SMCK Gesundheits äh äh smart media Card,
Connector. Äh die kann man auch äh rausnehmen. Sie haben ja behauptet, wir werden fest eingebaut und ähm die Thematik,
ähm möchte da jetzt auch nicht einfach äh die ganze Zeit in der Schussdiene stehen und betont natürlich auch wieder, dass sie sagt, na ja, wir haben ja damals den Vorschlag eingebracht, aber dann haben die CGM gesagt, ja da haben sie keinen Bock mehr. Ähm,
Und dann hat wurde irgendwie dagegen gestimmt äh so ganz schlecht ist die Idee ja vielleicht doch nicht. Ähm,
Na ja, mal schauen, ob da nach noch Bewegung reinkommt. Ich glaube, da ist einfach noch genauso lange Bewegung drin, wie die Ärztinnen und Ärzte das aufrecht erhalten, dass sie halt diesen,
ja Betrug und diese Plünderung,
nicht mehr länger mitmachen. Ja, ich denke, das ist der der entscheidende äh Punkt, der hier mal passieren muss und das äh müsste jetzt andere Leute aufrechterhalten und äh,
den Druck aufrecht erhalten, als es der CCC kann, ja? Ähm da müssten jetzt, sind jetzt die.
Branchen und äh Ärztinnen, Verbände und was auch immer, die für was auch immer für äh marxistische Organisationen.
Die noch haben. Ja wollen wir für das letzte so ein Termin Jingle machen oder geben wir das einfach nur mal bekannt? Weiß ich nicht.
Einfach bekannt.
Es ist werbefreies Fernsehen, insofern könnten wir da vorher auch werben.
Ja, wir haben ja auch schon ganz oft dafür äh geworben, ähm es geht um den Film alles eins, außer der Null. Wo es um Bauerland geht, vor allem und,
primär ähm und ein bisschen die Geschichte des äh CCC.
Und du sagst ein paar Zeilen und ich sage eine und das kommt jetzt demnächst auf der Art,
Der ARD wird ausgestrahlt und das ist dann natürlich erstmal ein Live Vergnügen. Es wird zu der äh superpopulären Sendezeit 0Uhrzwanzig ausgesendet, damit's auch richtig alle mitkriegen, aber es wird ja danach.
Danach ist in der Mediathek.
Und so und das äh sollte den Zugang äh zu diesem Film dann doch nochmal deutlich verbessern.
Ich hatte doch irgendwo kürzlich auch noch mal davon gehört, dass da eine Kino da hatte sich jemand bei uns gemeldet.
Ja du hast mich doch dahin geschickt.
Noch mal. Da war nochmal was. Da geht äh in München ist das äh warte mal, das will ich ganz schnell noch rausfinden.
Und zwar in Münch, ach so, scheiße ist das Datum noch gar nicht geplant. Der äh die Münchener Grünen werden das im Winter im Rahmen einer kleinen Filmreihe zeigen.
Aber noch nicht ein Datum mitgeteilt, die haben sich erstmal erkundigt, ob jemand vom CCC vielleicht dahin kommt. Äh jetzt müssen sie's aber machen, jetzt.
So schnell. Ist ja egal. Auf jeden Fall hat die ARD hatten äh Datum mitgeteilt, das schon mal ganz gut. Dienstag der dreizehnte Zwölfte.
Um null Uhr zwanzig, also ich vermute mal, dass es dann äh schreiben Sie, ah, da schreiben Sie sogar. Pfiffig,
na ja, ich weiß ja, wenn man sagt jetzt ähm null Uhr zwanzig ist das Dienstag und dann Fernsehen, dann weiß ja wieder keiner meint das jetzt das Dienstagsprogramm war's noch in den.
In der Nacht vom Montag auf Dienstag.
Das steht tatsächlich auf dieser Webseite auch genauso. Das finde ich jetzt für dich mal bemerkenswert.
Problem erfasst, Problemen gelöst. Hervorragend. Also ihr müsst Montag lange aufbleiben, Mitte Dienstag früh um null Uhr zwanzig das live sehen könnt.
Nacht von Montag auf Dienstag den dreizehnten zwölften zweiundzwanzig ja.
Also wenn ihr jetzt eure Videorekorde nicht programmiert bekommt, können wir euch auch nicht helfen.
Und weißt du was ich richtig schön schütte? Aus gegebenem Anlass ist es am 13.12. ist. Ich find's super.
Ich sage da jetzt nichts. Nö, ich auch nicht. Aber ihr kriegt ja schon.
Ich sage da jetzt nichts zu, aber er hätte er hätte ein schlechteres Datum sein können.
Hätte, definitiv. Hätten sie aber auch um dreizehn Uhr zwölf senden können. Kinderprogramm. So, das war heute eine,
Sendung, Twitter lastige Sendung, aber,
Eigentlich ganz gut, dass äh würde ich da auch mal so ein bisschen das trifft auch mal wirklich so den den Kern von Netz und Politik wirklich äh auch.
Ja, den politischen Teil haben wir wahrscheinlich fast äh ähm noch ein bisschen, noch ein bisschen kleingehalten. Aber ähm.
Netzpolitik, Netz, Gesellschaftspolitik, also es betrifft halt die Gesellschaft. Und betrifft auch alle und vor allem betrifft's mich, weil ich ich wüsste ja, was ich von Twitter haben wollen würde. Also wenn er das.
Eier, was andersfarbigen Haken, ich wähle auf jeden Fall.
Also wie gesagt, Haken ist mir eigentlich äh äh Schnupper, aber ich hätte nichts dagegen ein äh so eine Art verifiziertes äh Account Impressum
zu haben, so wie auch immer sie das äh machen. Technisch möchte ich vor allem nicht ihre scheiß Clans benutzen müssen, sondern ich will einfach, dass ich,
mit meinem Account auch quasi in äh mitfinanzieren kann und,
auch benutzen kann, sodass ich mal wieder eine eine illustre ähm App Landschaft um diesen Dienst herum bildet und das kann meinetwegen ausschließlich nur für Bezahle sein, ja? Das
da zahle ich auch 20 Dollar im Monat. Ganz ehrlich würde ich machen.
Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich finde auch immer überrascht. Also ich benutze einen relativ alten Twitter-Client, der ich ich habe da gar keine Werbung. Das wird einfach in meinem Client gefiltert.
Ja, deswegen kann ich das auch ertragen. Ich ich will,
will keine Werbung sehen, mich interessiert Werbung nicht, ich will die Tweets sehen, ich will die in der Reihenfolge sehen, wie ich sie will, ich will 'ne App haben, die auf alles Zugriff hat, die alle Features hat, die dann auch irgendwie Book mags und diesen ganzen anderen
äh kann. Derzeit sind ja diese äh beschnitten und das das ist so das, was ich mir
wünsche. So und da würde ich bis zu 20 Euro äh zahlen im Monat so, weil da zahlst du sogar für so ein blödes Spiegel ab, wo du dann immer noch mit Werbung zugekotzt wirst.
Ja, wobei ich jetzt sagen würde, dass die durchschnittliche Inhaltsqualität beim Spiegel dann doch Twitter noch überschreitet. Auch wenn ein größerer in größerer Teil der Spiegelmeldungen tatsächlich von Twitter kommen aber ähm.
Na ja, also,
Ich sah ja nur, ich würde es so machen, dass das andere Leute äh nicht unbedingt genauso sehen würden. Äh ist klar, aber für mich ist ja Twitter auch ein professionelles Tool. Für mich ist ist das einfach ein wichtiger Zugang zum zum Netz, darüber bekomme ich eine Menge Informationen, darüber halte ich Kontakt,
kann ich auch irgendwie so eine Community mit ähm,
Spielen oder mit ihr kommunizieren und das für mich alles hilfreich und das ist mir äh allemal wert.
Aber ich kann dir eins sagen.
Dass sie das einbauen werden.
Wir werden eine wir werden nach dieser Sendung äh relativ viel negatives Feedback aus zwei Gründen bekommen. Erstens, dass wir es uns nicht äh mit dem Untergang der Welt auseinander
gesetzt haben, der nun unmittelbar bevorsteht, weil ein ähm,
Exzentrischer Milliardär diese Kommunikationsplattform gekauft hat und äh wir werden uns äh der Kritik aussetzen müssen, dass wir nicht ausreichend für Masterdon geworben haben. Äh deswegen werbe ich jetzt nochmal für Masterdom.
Nicht. Okay, sag mal, warum ich das machen soll?
Ich bin äh ad äh Linuzifer at Knot Social und nach äh Invites zu Chaos Punkt Social braucht nicht mehr gefragt zu werden, weil,
dass da jetzt das Wachstum Wachstum Grenzen gesetzt wurden und weil,
Äh das ja das Besondere an Masterunia ist, dass es föderiert ist. Das heißt, ihr könnt auf egal welcher Masse dort instant sein,
und ähm das soll auch äh,
Motiviert werden, damit es nicht so wird wie bei Jabba, wo am Ende alle äh auf CCC-Chauber-Server äh sind.
Das war schon die ganze Werbung. Was ist denn so cool daran?
Also tatsächlich funktioniert's genauso, ne? Also man kann jetzt schon einfach mal sagen, dass es ähm,
Also von der von der Funktionalität her äh keine Einschränkungen gibt, ja. Also das heißt, das Entscheidende ist, am Ende, wo bildet sich die die die sinnvolle Community?
Und das kann natürlich grundsätzlich auf Masterdon genauso gut funktionieren äh wie auf Twitter.
Und ob das passiert, hängt natürlich daran, ob die Leute dahin gehen oder nicht.
Und insofern ist das ja durchaus zu unterstützen, ähm dahin zu wandern.
Ja okay, das war also jetzt kein kein flammender Appell, würde ich sagen. Weil das ganze Versprechen ist, ja, es könnte genauso werden vielleicht.
Na ja, bei Twitter wird's auf jeden Fall nicht so bleiben, ne? Das muss man ja auch mal.
Aber ja, das muss aber auch nichts Schlechtes sein. Also das wissen wir ja jetzt noch nicht. Ja, aber ich meine.
Es heißt ja nicht ohne Grund Social Network, so man hat ja sozusagen da sein also ich habe da sozusagen jetzt einen Account, der ist irgendwie seit über zehn Jahren,
fein getunt und der hat irgendwie seine Blocklisten da da weiß ich wer die Leute sind äh ich lerne immer wieder neue Leute,
Kennen oder ich weiß zumindest, wo ich nachschauen muss, um irgendwie auf neue Quellen äh zu kommen. All das ist in diesem anderen Netzwerk halt verloren.
Ja und aber ja.
Bei null anfangen.
Und und wird sich da in anderer Form zeigen und in anderer Form realisieren. Also da muss man jetzt äh da kannst du natürlich beim alte Leute Netzwerk Twitter bleiben, Tim?
Nee, aber ich meine, das nimmt ja sozusagen an, dass das dass das andere Netzwerk auch den selben Zuschnitt haben wird
So und das das ist so dieselbe Ausrichtung hat und dass sozusagen dieselben Themen dort diskutiert werden oder das auf dieselbe Art und Weise diskutiert wird und das davon gehe ich halt überhaupt nicht aus.
Na ja, wir werden's sehen. Wir machen jetzt auf jeden Fall erst mal Schluss,
Wie gesagt, vielen Dank äh für eure Unterstützung und auch vielen Dank, wenn ihr äh die jetzt äh mal erstmalig aufnehmt und.
Nein, das das kostet einfach jetzt acht Euro hier.
Ach, wir machen jetzt LNP blue.
Ja. 8 Euro im Monat fertig.
Ja. Ganz einfach, aber Abo-Modell. Und was bieten wir dann für einen Mehrwert?
Ihr kriegt alle einen blauen Haken. An jede Folge kommt blauer Hacken, wenn ihr die gehört habt.
Geil. Das machen wir. Super. Alles klar.
Wir wir können ja hier nix ändern. Wir wollen das ja hier für die Menschheit erhalten.
Ja, aber vielleicht gibt's bald auch mal wieder einen neuen tollen ähm,
Merch und äh das erzählen wir euch aber später irgendwann. Jetzt äh schicken wir euch erstmal ins Bett. Gute Nacht.